Hey everybody there were live.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is an all in one platform
to make your own website fast and easy.
A professional website,
whether it's for home or for business,
it's very easy to do with Squarespace.
Simple drag and drop interface,
24 seven support. If you panic and you
freaked out, it's but it's so easy to do,
you're not going to.
If you can use an email and if you could
send pictures in an email and just do
the normal drag and drop stuff and click
on things like if you're not completely
illiterate when it comes to using
your computer to get online,
you can make your own website website
and make a website that's really nice.
Squarespace has a simple easy to use
interface that really you can't go wrong
with and they also have it really set
up very easily to make an online store.
If you want to start ecommerce, he wants
starts selling things from your website.
If you have a small business and if
you're a musician, you want to sell music,
they have it set up that you could
have digital downloads very quickly and
easily. Can't say enough good
things about Squarespace.
We have a ton of friends that have
used it. A Duncan Trussell uses it.
Kara Santa Maria uses it.
It's just really easy now to
make and manage your own website.
It used to be an incredibly difficult
thing that everybody has to have to pay a
lot of money to do, but with
Squarespace it's easy. It's cheap.
Plants Start at eight bucks a month
and includes a free domain name.
If you sign up for a year.
Responsive designs that work
on all platforms including
portable platforms like
I iPhones, android phones, windows,
pcs with Unix, Linux, everything. Mac,
it works on everything and for a free
trial and 10% off your first purchase,
go to squarespace.com and
enter the code word Joe.
They also have a logo creator where if
you're starting up your own business,
you can create a clean, simple logo
designed for yourself in minutes. Very,
very easy to do. I mean,
Squarespace is, it just,
I can't say enough good things about
them and what's important to me.
I can't say enough good things
about the people that run it.
I met a bunch of the guys
that work for Squarespace, um,
when I was in New York and they were
super cool, which means a lot to me. Uh,
it's nice to know that the people that
you're working with are actually nice
people.
So go to squarespace.com and enter the
code word Joe and get 10% off your first
purchase,
free trial and 10% off squarespace.com
and enter the code word Joe.
We're also brought to you by on at.com
on it is a human optimization website.
What we sell is a bunch of shit that
makes your body and your life work better.
Things like strength and conditioning
equipment like kettle bells and battle
ropes, all shit that Steve
Maxwell knows a lot about.
We sell ab wheels, medicine
balls, things along those lines.
We also sell healthy snack foods
like hemp force protein bars,
very nutritious and healthy
hemp protein powder with very,
very little sugar. Um, well the hemp
force protein powder that we saw,
we buy the finest protein powder
from Canada. Unfortunately,
hopefully we're going to be able to
buy it in America now because they've
changed a lot of the laws now at least
statewide allowing people to grow hemp.
A lot of misconceptions
when it comes to hemp, uh,
the big one is that somehow or another
you could test positive for marijuana at
your job. You know, if you
have a job that tests you,
you don't have to worry about it.
Hemp has zero THC in it.
You're not going to test positive for it.
But I should let you know that
if you eat poppy seed bagels,
you can test positive for heroin. I
know that sounds crazy, but it is true.
It's happened to someone I know. Uh, you
have to be careful about that. In fact,
a guy was imprisoned in Jew in Dubai
because they had one of those weird drug
test things they do at their airports.
They have like some sophisticated drug
sniffing mechanisms and this guy had
eaten a poppy seed Bagel Heathrow airport
and he had poppy seeds on his body.
So he tested positive for heroin
with they're sniffing machine.
They locked this fucking guy in jail
and they had to figure out that, oh,
you just ate a Bagel. Okay. And
they let them go, whoa. Anyway,
[inaudible] you don't have to worry
about that. I'll, I'll any of that shit.
And a very high in protein, very
nutritious and very, very low in sugar.
In fact,
a one portion of hemp force protein
powder only has one gram of naturally
occurring sugar. And uh, I think
when we talked to Steve Maxwell,
he'll agree with me that sugar super bad
for you. A lot of people like that shit.
You got to get off at folks.
Sugar is probably one of the worst
things for your body. Fucking terrible,
unfortunately. Terrible and
delicious. Like much like life is.
There's a yin and a Yang to this shit.
Anyway,
all the stuff that we sell at [inaudible]
dot com is explained in detail on the
site. We tried to sell the very
best stuff that we can buy,
whether it's organic coconut oil, we
sell this new thing called a warrior bar,
which is all buffalo meat and
cranberries with no preservatives,
no antibiotics, no nitrates, no
added hormones, very, very healthy.
And it's got 14 grams of protein per bar
and only four grams of fat and healthy
fat, no Msg, no soy, no lactose,
gluten free, no nitrates,
no antibiotics or added hormones.
Very, very good for you, very healthy.
And uh, all the stuff we sell it on. It
is all stuff that I use and uh, go there,
enjoy and use the codeword Rogan to
save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right, well I fuck around Steven
Maxwell's here, Cuban music. Jamie
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast,
my knight.
Good to see you,
my friend.
Great to see you again to Steve Maxwell.
Uh, is uh, for folks who don't know,
a long time Brazilian Jujitsu,
black belt,
long time strength and conditioning guru.
Uh,
and my friend and I found out
about you, uh, DVDs. Actually,
I think someone from the underground
posted up a link to one of your DVDs a
while back and I got one of
your Kettlebell Dvds, um,
which I thought was a very
informative and very interesting.
And then I started reading about your
lifestyle and reading about your,
your philosophies on training and you're
reading some of your blog entries and
uh,
you're a,
you're an unusual dude when it comes
to the strength and conditioning and
fitness and you know, just uh, the,
the wellness advocates, you know,
usually have a bunch of different schools
of thought when it comes to those.
He got meatheads who would just send to
lifting the heaviest weights that they
can and getting as big as they can.
But you're sort of a Weirdo man.
You're like traveling the world, you're
doing seminars all over the place. You're,
you're eating very little food.
You're, you know, you're, you've,
you've sort of like,
I've got a lot of people interested in
how you're living your life these days.
Well, I've definitely gone
through an evolution. You know,
I've been at this for 51 years.
I started when it was like 10 years old.
That's when you started working out.
When I was 10, my father got me a, uh,
a York barbell set. York was just down
the road from Carlisle, Pennsylvania.
And uh, I was one of those kids that
was sort of weakened, scrawny and uh,
basically getting picked on by some
of the neighborhood kids. And My,
my father kind of saw
where this was going,
got me the barbell Sapp and I
literally made me go out for wrestling,
really made me,
I went kicking and screaming and then I
found out it was actually pretty good at
it.
Will you, uh, you must be happy, you
must have thanked him at some point?
Oh, for sure. Absolutely. I mean,
he had tried to teach us both me and
my brother boxing and so forth in the
backyard. And uh, I, I learned
early. I didn't like to get hit,
but I sure would like to
clinch it. Take guys down, man.
Well that's a sign of intelligence.
It was just a natural evolution.
And then I discovered, hey man, I can
barely got this thing for wrestling.
And all my training was geared to making
me a better athlete as opposed to the
body beautiful.
Or even a power lifting
or Olympic lifting.
I was always interested in improved
performance for my chosen activity.
And back then that wasn't
that common. Right. I mean,
back then everybody was trying
to be like Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Everybody was trying to lift
weights and get huge and,
well,
this was in the 60s and at that point
bodybuilding was still in its infancy.
I mean,
up to up to the 1950s,
bodybuilding was actually a really
honorable profession. It was, it was pure.
There was no antibiotic steroids.
I mean,
they didn't even have so much
as a Flintstone vitamin. I mean,
there was no creatine or
protein powders and stuff.
What was the Diet like back then when,
when guys would like, try to get big?
Like did they have any idea of what the,
what the correct foods to eat?
Well, yeah, for sure. A lot more
emphasis was placed on health.
Health was always first with
a lot of these old, old, uh,
bodybuilders and, and um,
they called themselves physical is right
now. Jacqueline [inaudible]
was one of those guys.
Why have I first heard that
term from you actually from,
I believe it was reading your blog or,
or reading something that you had a
conversation that you'd had with someone,
but, uh, the, the term physical culture,
like being involved in physical culture.
I like that term. It's a good term, but
it's a throw back to ancient Greece.
And then if you think about it,
the standard for male beauty and male
excellence for 2000 years was the ancient
Greek statue, the Greek God,
thank God. And you know,
if you look at the sculpture from
that time, it's just magnificent.
Something got very skewed right towards
the end of the sixties, early seventies.
And a lot of it was the anabolic steroids.
And you know, guys, let's, let's face it,
it's the human condition,
right?
If people will do things because they
can do things and people just wanted to
get as big and freaky as possible.
It's a bit of dysmorphia too, isn't it?
Isn't it sort of like,
like an anorexic that doesn't
realize there it's so skinny look in,
or a woman who has enormous fake press
and still doesn't think they're big
enough.
There's some sort of a weird psychological
condition where people can't see
themselves connect in there
somewhere where they, they, they,
they have a very skewed images, body
image of themselves. But, uh, yeah,
back in the 60s, it was pretty innocent
still. I mean, steroids existed,
but it wasn't prevalent.
Most of the information,
if you're looking for really good solid
information about sports training, uh,
you have to go before 1950. Really?
Yeah. Why is that? Well, I mean,
that's when steroids be, uh, began to
make inroads into Olympic weightlifting.
And of course that's when the eastern
block really started getting into this
stuff. Of course, it's not like, you
know, the u s didn't have, you know,
plenty of drugs too. Sure. But in those
days, you know, it was still legal, uh,
in the, in the early days. But you had
asked me about what the guys eat back,
the money mighty men of all just normal
food. It's just good basic food. Uh,
they drank a lot of milk.
Milk was considered a bodybuilding
food and you can trace that color back,
you know, thousands of years ago, even
into a India where they would, uh,
the Hindu wrestlers would
drink the milk and eat,
eat almonds in an effort to get
a build mass and their bodies.
So it's been well known.
Well everyone, you know,
talks about lactose intolerance
and things along those lines.
But a big issue with lactose intolerance
is just homogenized and pasteurized
milk. And you know, I've talked about
that in the podcast and people have said,
yeah, well if you don't do that,
people are going to get sick.
And that's not because of the milk. It's
because of the way we're raising cattle.
It's because of what we're
putting in these animals' diets.
It's because these aren't healthy animals
and if these aren't healthy animals
and the milk isn't treated properly,
if it does get somehow or
another contaminated by ECO
law or things along those
lines,
that's not because the milk is bad.
It's because somehow or another it
was handled poorly and people got sick
because of it.
But idea that
pasteurization and homogenization is
the only way to go with milk is really
ridiculous.
It kills all the enzyme.
It is ridiculous.
I mean,
people have been drinking milk literally
for thousands of years. I mean,
animal husband rate
goes back 10,000 years.
And to my way of thanking
the modern cow is just a,
I mean,
it's just a very sickly animal.
Even though they give these things
steroids and they give them all sorts of
antibiotics and, and all this
stuff, they're feeding them grain.
Cattle were never meant to eat grain.
They eat grass in the nature in the wild.
And then like you said,
you know,
you super heat the milk and you cook it
literally to death until there's nothing
left in it. No wonder people
have. And then on top of that,
people are drinking milk
combined with all others,
other kinds of stuff and overburdening
the digestive system, uh,
over drinking milk and you know, your
body be, develops an intolerance.
Yeah. People have this
aversion to bacteria. Uh,
but what folks have to get in their heads,
like this idea that
homogenization pasteurization
is the only way to go because
it kills all the bad stuff, but it also
kills the good stuff. I mean, sure,
you're going to get some protein,
calcium out of milk that's homogenize it,
pasteurize, but you're taking in
cultures, when you're drinking milk,
you're taking in a part
of that animal's body,
and the closer it is to being alive,
the better it is for your body.
That's why meat is supposed to
be consumed medium rare or rare.
Like that's the best way to eat meat.
You're going to get the most nutrition
out of that food when they're,
the only time you're supposed
to cook a, uh, like meat past.
That is when the animal
is assumed to be sick.
Like the reason why we cook pork to
150 degrees is to kill trick a gnosis.
And that's one of the reasons why with,
um, with factory pork or with, um,
you know, uh, what's the best word
for it? Farm pork or domestic pork.
Domestic pork. They're now saying that
you, they're lowering their standard.
They're lowering it down to I believe
140 or 145 degrees because the incidences
of tricking osis are so rare.
In fact,
90% of all trick and osis cases in this
country come from eating bear meat.
Interesting. I've had their made by the
way, it's delicious. It was absolutely,
it was black bear, corn fed,
black bear corn fed the bear.
The bear had actually been living outside
this farmers field and a friend of
mine, uh, actually shot this thing and uh,
had prepared steaks and had told me,
hey listen,
I'm coming up to Philly to
train some Jujitsu with him.
This guy was a firearms expert.
He,
he actually taught farms for the FBI and
he used to take Brazilian Jujitsu with
me when I had my school in Philadelphia.
So I'm thinking, Oh my God,
bear state sends really sick man.
So I was trying to think of every excuse
for not eating it right. So he comes up,
he takes my wife out for shooting
lesson at the local range.
I in the meantime,
make some dinner for myself and then I'm
going to give them the excuse why I was
so hungry. I could wait. Right. So he's
so hurt. He's so hurt because you know,
he had made this specially for me. So
I says, Oh, what the hell, you know,
I'll have a bite dude.
It was absolutely delicious.
And then it was ashamed of myself. Like,
wow man, I wish I would have waited for,
you know,
so I saved it and had it the next night.
Yeah. Bear is very good for
you. Shockingly delicious.
You just have to make sure he cook it
correctly. Like a smoky beef. Yeah.
But I was also asked to make sure that
the animal hasn't been eating a lot of
fish. When they eat a lot
of fish, they can get funky.
Like if you eat bear or if he,
you catch a bear that's been eaten like
a rotten Mousse. And then for real, yeah,
any kind of Scavenger,
yeah, we're the scavenging
and so forth. But you know,
back to a quality of food and so forth.
An awful lot depends on a person's
ability to digest their food.
It's all comes back to digestion.
If you can't digest it,
then you can't assimilate it.
And a lot of the molecules of this
undigested food passes through the gut
membrane and creates this
inflammatory response in the body.
That's how these people are getting a
lot of their food intolerances and so
forth. When the digestion is in
line, your immune system is in wine,
you don't get sick bacteria
doesn't bother you. I mean the,
I in many cases when the immune
system is really, really strong, you,
you even fight off cases of worms
and all sorts of stuff. Your body is,
is amazing.
And his resilience.
Do you follow anything like a Gracie diet
or one of those things where you, uh,
don't combine foods to give your
digestive system a bit of a break?
Yeah, very much so. Uh, I was
originally introduced, uh,
to the Gracie diet by Horian Gracie,
the oldest son of Leo.
And then later Elio himself,
I spent some time with Leo actually stayed
down to his ranch for almost a month,
one time and Brazil. And Really? Wow.
That must have been amazing. Oh Man.
It was,
what year was this?
This was the year that hoist fought in
couple of Kabbalah and lost the villages.
Ah, okay. So that was probably
[inaudible] 96 [inaudible] 97. Yeah,
somewhere around there. Yeah. I want to
say maybe a little off might be 98 99.
Let's find out. Anyway, yeah, I forget.
But at any rate, uh, that's
when I was, became aware of
food combining. And then I,
I did a lot of research and reading
about it. I read about this guy,
Herbert Shelton,
who had a clinic in San Antonio,
Texas and cured a lot of people from a
lot of different diseases and sicknesses
using food combining and fasting.
So I got really, really interested.
And then later I read this guy,
Doctor John Tilden,
who wrote a book called toxemia explained.
He was a turn of the century physician
and he cured many so called incurable
diseases just through
diet and fasting alone.
And the basic premise is when you
over mix a lot of food in one meal,
there's a real tendency to overeat.
When you overeat,
you overburden your digestive system
and of course there's a real tendency to
put on body fat. So when you eat,
just let's say for example, uh,
I have a fruit based meal, a starch
based meal and a protein based meal.
Occasionally I'll have some
light dairy with the fruit,
but a lot of times it's just fruit butso
occasionally a little bit of nuts with
a starch meal I will usually stick stick
with something like a sweet potatoes or
potato, but occasionally I'll
have wheat based product.
I don't have any gluten
problems whatsoever,
mostly because of the way I combined
my foods and I can have that with some
vegetables and so forth.
And then I'll have a a protein meal and
all these meals are interchangeable.
I out of my protein meal for breakfast,
I could have my protein
meal for lunch and so forth.
And usually with the protein meal,
if it's really cold or I'm really hungry,
I'll have a little soup and I'll have
a raw leaf, green vegetable salad,
occasionally a couple
of cooked vegetables,
but basically meat and
vegetables and when I say meet,
I'm talking about fish
fowl, you know, all,
all of the type of flesh
foods and so forth.
And since adopting that I feel fantastic.
I'm like 61 years old now.
I still feel really good,
you know?
I've been able to maintain a really low
fat percentage and keep my energy and
health because traveling is brutal man.
I mean I'm in a different country every
couple a couple of weeks and as you got
flying can kick your ass man in a two hour
flight, 12 or if I, it doesn't matter,
it just really debilitating to fly.
Something about the air and the
I I radiation as well. Yeah,
the electromagnetic fields from the plane.
I mean there's a lot of stuff that's
hidden that people don't even realize they
can make flying pretty hard
in your system. But I do okay.
I really do.
The radiation thing, it's pretty
shocking. When I first started, uh,
someone was talking about x rays,
I said, all right, well let's,
let's look up how much
radiation x ray does.
Cause you have fucking airplanes
way more than x rays. And you know,
people do it all the time,
all the time and put those
poor stewardesses and flight
attendants and pilots.
I mean, those guys must be
beat down on a regular basis.
It's very a, your body, once again,
your immune system, when, when you're,
when you're eating in accordance with
nature and you're not overburdening the
system over burdening your
digestive system and so forth, uh,
your immune system is pretty strong.
Your body can handle just about anything
really, but it does make you tired.
It can make you quite tired.
So rest becomes really important.
And I don't know about you,
but like I know you fly all
over the place to do your, uh,
your comedy act and so forth.
And, uh, I find that if,
if I rest up really well and
don't do anything too strenuous,
I bounced back pretty quick.
I find that I'm also, um, I
have to exercise when I land,
when I land, that's my, my secret to
avoiding the real feelings of jet lag.
I get to the gym,
I hit the elliptical machine and I just
do a hard half an hour on the elliptical
machine.
Just something about it forces my body
into that sort of recovery response and
that kicks everything up a notch and just
seems to really help keep my energy at
high levels when I fly.
But depending on what
time of the day, oh, am a,
what am I sacred for making the
transition. The second I get on the plane,
I reset my watch to whatever
times they're not going to be yet.
Sometimes I'm flying many times zones.
And then I immediately tried to adapt
my eating plan to the place and gone,
which means often skipping a meal.
Uh,
occasional I'll even fast and not just
drink water the whole time on the plane
and donating. And I figure it's a
low activity anyway. And then, um,
the second event, I'm like, you, if
it's in the early part of the day,
I'll take a nice walk.
I,
I do this thing called Russian breathing
matters where I worked the breath. Uh,
it's fantastic. It's, you
matched the, the, uh, the inhale,
exhale to your steps,
and you see how many steps you can get
up to on the inhale and how many steps
you can get it on the exhale.
So you might be taking like 20 steps in
one inhale and actually having over 20
steps and you'll keep that going.
That's really interesting. Um, I do
something similar in the isolation tank.
Just to, to clarify what I said
earlier, I was an incorrect, uh,
it's actually the same as an x ray, a
seven hour flight from New York to London.
You received the same dose of radiation
as a chest x ray from New York,
New York to Tokyo. It's two chest x rays.
So that's where I had gotten it wrong.
So, you know, six, seven hour
flight, it's like an x ray.
I mean, like when you go to the
dentist, right? You always see the, uh,
the hygienist jumped behind the curtain.
She doesn't want to be when you're
supposed to just doing this extra right.
Horrible is x Ray. But you didn't ever
see her in the room with you, man.
It's covering your balls
and your, your, your, your,
your chest and thyroid with,
with that, that shield.
So obviously it's not as harmless,
especially if you think about poor
pilots, you know, I mean that's,
that's pretty crazy when you really stop
and think about it. It's pretty nuts.
Oh Man. So you were, it was 98,
which says hoist Gracie's
will lead Ishmael fight. Um,
so you went down there in 1998 you
stayed for a month with Elio Gracie.
So folks who don't know,
Helio Gracie is one of the most important
figures in the history of martial arts,
if not the most important.
Him and Carlos Gracie, uh,
essentially created what we
call modern Brazilian Jujitsu.
They started the revolution.
And since then there's been
a lot of innovation and a
lot of change and a lot of
growth since that time, since the, you
know, the 1940s and 50s. And sixties,
and the on through the Hixson hoists,
you know,
all these guys that came up
afterwards, you know, through the 90s.
And then once the ultimate fighting
championship came around, boy,
it just skyrocketed.
Now Jujitsu and your son Max is a really,
Zack, excuse me, exact
Maxwell, excuse me. Zach, um,
fought and metamorris. Yeah. Yeah, he,
uh, wow. He really did a terrific job.
That kid was Tuffy flats.
That's Sean Roberts. Yeah.
That guy's like a real submission machine.
So, you know, I was a little nervous,
but that is slick. He's slick,
very relaxed guy. But you know,
he was one of the first generation of
American children to grow up in the
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu system. I started
him when he was really just a little,
you know,
uh,
when I was laughing when chrom is talking
about the invisible Jujitsu, you know,
more like invisible
pressure. Well, I wasn't,
so I started with the pressure
I put on poor Zach, but he,
he really, uh, he grew
up in that whole system.
Was that because of like the way your
father pushed you into wrestling?
Uh, probably, you know, it
was not conscious thing.
I had a little bit of that little egg
syndrome going on there and uh, maybe, uh,
maybe looking to, you
know, live some type of,
get some type of fulfillment
through my kids. You know,
I mean there was all that crap going on.
Well, I have girls, but a, I teach them
Jujitsu, but I make it fun. You know,
I have them arm bar me and just show
them where to put their legs and how to
pull and how to, you know, how to set up
the position. And I showed them the mount.
But what's really fascinating is,
you know what,
you're familiar with the concept that
there's certain things that get passed on
through genetics. In fact, uh,
they've proven that with certain mice
that they can take mice and they can
institute,
they put a smell in the air and when
that smell happens and you're like a
citrusy smell, they'll give it an
electrical shock to the feet of the mice.
Like they have what they're
standing on this thing.
And when they smelled this smell, the
zap their feet not did not to kill them,
you know, just enough to like
make them like realize like,
Yikes, this is not good.
Their children with no
electricity whatsoever,
smell that smell and a panic ensues.
They have a panic response.
So it's passed on through their
genetics. Cellular memory. Yes.
My three year old when
her and my four year old,
well heard my five year
old started rolling around,
the three year old would take
the back and go over under, okay.
She throws the hooks in and she goes
like this and she hangs on. I was like,
that's crazy. I was like, she's,
it's almost like instinct.
Like they were rolling around and um,
the older daughter like turned sideways
and the three year old went like this
and then through her legs over. And
I was like, that is fucking crazy.
Because she did what I've
done probably 100,000 times,
you know, but it's in my mind, you
see the back, you get that over under,
you throw the hooks on.
I mean,
it's just instinctively so to see a
little three year old immediately do it.
I'm like,
I wonder if that's in their genes.
I wonder if that has somehow
or another had been passed on.
I made, we will never know,
but it's an interesting theory.
We May in our lifetime, I mean, we may,
they may be able to say they might
be able to figure that luminate
that human beings are natural.
Grapplers all mammals are
grapplers. I mean, even Orca,
we'll wrestle sharks.
There was an amazing film in New Zealand,
have some tourists that uh,
uh,
there was a female worker with her
calf training the calf, how to hunt.
She grabbed,
she hit a great white from underneath
and stunned it and grabbed it and turned
it over. Sharks need to continuously
move in order to breathe.
When they turn over,
for some reason they go dos owl.
So she held it upside down
until it drowned and then he,
then they ate the liver.
Once again. Grapplers man,
if you think about it in nature,
prey animals,
our strikers and predators are crap.
Where's the short cats would have cats
do immediately they get ahold of the neck
and then they dive under the
go to full guard. You know,
I mean that's super common
in the cap world. Yeah.
There's a crazy video of a lion,
a female lion killing a Willdabeast and a,
the way she kills the will to be,
it's not a wildebeest. Um, with
those pig looking things, not,
oh, it was a wart hog. Yeah. I
guess the Lord Her rock. Sure. Yeah.
Crazy looking at Tuskegee.
But she,
she dives on it. She bites his neck
and then she rolls under it. I mean,
she pulls garden this wart hog and then
slowly chokes it out and kills it by
holding onto its neck.
And it's fascinating to watch because
it's totally lik watching Jujitsu. I was,
I was in ballet and I
stayed right across the, uh,
the road from the monkey sanctuary and
the place where I was staying in bally,
uh, the monkeys was just overrun
the place a couple of times a day.
The whole troop and just come walking
through hundreds of them writers, man,
he's got us scary.
Don't leave your iPhone laying around you,
your room key or anything cause little
suckers will grab it and then you get to,
you have to bribe them to get it back.
But as watch these that
happened with you and that,
well I almost got my iPhone but uh,
I,
I would be working on my iPad a lot of
times cause I make my living to a online
personal training, uh,
aside from seminars.
So I'd always be working at the wee
hours in the morning when this monkey
trooper come through.
So I bought like just one of these cheap
little wooden slingshots and you know,
you don't even have to
shoot at the monkey.
You just pull it back and they
start to scream and run away.
They're smart enough to know like,
I guess enough people are shot at him,
you know, said they would take
off and leave me alone. But uh,
I would watch these young bunkies
wrestling and my God, it was Jujitsu.
They were using the guard. They put the
feet in the hips, it flip each other over.
They would go to the bank.
It was really fun to watch the little
suckers doing Jujitsu with each other in
the morning. And of course they use the
neck bite like, like you know, like a cat.
And you ever seen the
documentary grizzly man? I,
I saw the one part where the, the bears
going on it. Yeah. Fascinating. Yeah,
the documentary, the whole
thing. Oh, it's incredible.
It's one of my favorite dog was Werner
Herzog. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. Yeah,
I did see part of that. I
kept thinking to myself, the
hotel, what does this guy thank you
man. You're just, you're just a meal.
He was crazy. He had a lot
of issues for sure. I mean,
as you delve deep into the documentary,
all these different people from his past
are talking about how crazy was. Uh,
it's uh, it's actually an
unintentionally hilarious documentary.
It's really quite funny.
But when the bears are going
at it, it's a full Jujitsu.
It just full guard. The bag gets side
control at one point. I mean it's,
and then the other bear hip escapes and
gets back to guard. I mean it's, he, it's,
it's crazy.
I mean you watch how they're doing it.
It's like these bears are using a
form of Jujitsu. It's very similar.
Back in the 70s,
I uh,
went down to Atlantic city and I
used to be really into arm wrestling.
It was but actually pretty good.
And I actually won the, uh,
the East Coast resort championship in
Atlantic city. My weight in Ann Arbor,
that was college wrestler at the time.
I wrestled a division one Ncaa and uh,
did a lot of straight training
in those days and uh, the, the,
the halftime entertainment was victor the
wrestling bear and do you remember the
karate guy movie guys?
Tank Guy? Joe Has No,
he was fairly well known a
martial arts guy at the time.
He did a lot of Hollywood's
not work and so forth. Anyway,
he went out to wrestle Fichter,
the wrestling bear and it was amazing
how this bear would use single leg take
downs.
Really.
It would grab him behind the Achilles and
put his big old bare shoulder and head
against the thigh to take him down.
It was just really amazing to
watch this bear go to work.
Like he actually had moves or something
and he would go for a low single,
he met and he would take this big, this
guy probably weighed about two 40 to 50.
This Joe has and have you saw him,
you'd probably recognize it.
He used to play a henchman and a
lot of movies and stuff. Anyway,
he was threatened.
This Joe has around and this was this
like a little black bear and then people
could wrestle the bear, you
know, uh, if they want it to.
The bear was muzzled of course.
And uh, it was really amazing, man.
You had to cover the bears
clause with anything.
Yeah, they had like a little
pads around the cause,
but you had no chance against his bare
man. I mean, no, no chance whatsoever.
Frighteningly strong. This animal
was, and it was really funny to watch.
Yeah.
The comparison there,
the relative comparison of strength
between a person and in animals.
It's ridiculous. We had a two
year old chimp on, um, uh,
news radio. This show
though is on, once we had,
I don't even think we
ever used it on the show.
I think it was one of those scenes.
It just got cut.
But the chimp was hanging around the
set and the chimp trainer and they were
explaining to me how you
can only have babies.
Like you can't have like
a grown adult male chimp,
like that crazy lady in Connecticut.
Like they don't do their face in.
And it wasn't her,
it was her friend,
her friend got got attacked by the champ.
But the woman who was keeping
this chimp was fucking insane.
Cause trainers even do that.
They
don't spend time alone with these things
because they're fucking dangerous.
They are dangerous.
And then they start to think and act
like they're human because they'd been
humanized.
And uh,
there's been cases where some of the
animals become sexually aggressive towards
the females magic as a,
it's basically a teenage mammo
and they don't have any outlet.
I mean, it's crazy. Yeah.
They don't have any sexual outlet
other than masturbation or frogs.
If they catch a frog. So you want to
catch a frog and they fuck a frog.
It's like 98 should have the
same genetics, 98% the leaders.
So they're going to have a lot of crazy
human characteristics and no morals,
ethics, no, you know,
they don't understand the concept
of doing someone harm. They,
it doesn't even mean anything to them.
But this two year old chimp that we had
was on my back and just plain with me,
just like smacking me like every now
and then, like just joking around,
I was like, this is freaky. How
strong this thing is. Crazy.
It's only like this big,
you know,
it was this little tiny thing and I was
holding it and it was like hanging on to
me and then it would like rotate on me
and then it like, like slap my back.
And I was like, Jesus Christ, this
little baby could probably fucked me up,
you know, and an imagined a
gorilla. Oh, I was, um, I was,
uh,
part of, uh, uh, Arthur Jones had,
or the inventor of Nautilus had a
ranch down in Florida and he was a,
he,
he used to be a animal hunter and trapper.
He used to catch the animals for
zoos. He had, um, white rhinos. Uh,
he has a huge herd of, uh, the, the
biggest, yeah. Yeah. This was in, uh,
Lake Helen,
Florida.
He had his big a nautilus medical sports
industries down there and, uh, you know,
he, he owns giant jumbo
airlines, airplanes.
He was a pilot and a,
I mean, it was crazy.
He had the biggest
private herd of elephants,
so he would fly them in on planes.
Uh, he, my, my father was a, a inspector
for the Federal Department of Agriculture.
He actually inspected Jones
elephants when they were,
that's how I got to go down to
the ranch and meet Arthur Jones.
I wouldn't even imagine you'd get
a fucking elephant on a plane. Uh,
they had those big cargo Jetson.
They would fly this military style.
Wow. Okay. That makes sense. And He,
uh, it was not a movie dumbo drop,
something like that.
But he was a,
he had was an elephant hunter at one
point and it felt pretty bad about
slaughtering elephants. So he decided
to do some conservation work. And, uh,
but at any rate, he had a, a peck
relo named Mickey and a this Mickey,
they actually a sedated at one time.
I put it on an old nautilus pullover
machines. It's pretty funny picture.
I actually, I had it in my gym at
one point, this gorilla, but a,
I saw Mickey throw a fit with its trainer
one time and a throw a head of cabbage
at the guy because it was pissed
off about something, I don't know,
but hit the guy in the head
and knocked him out. Wow.
Just a head of cabbage, dude.
Imagine the power. Maybe the guy
had a glass straw. I don't know.
It looked to me like it's
the side of the head,
but wow. Knocked this guy out, man. Yeah,
I bet it was 300 miles an hour for
sure. Man. That made you didn't win.
Not Win. I mean, it just gave you the idea
of just how powerful these animals are.
Bins.
Yeah.
We can't even wrap my head around what
an 800 pound primate would be like.
That's the kind of strength that they
would have. It would just be ridiculous.
A chimpanzee. They say that a
hundred is this him right here?
That Sam right there. The photo up
there on the screen. That's it. Wow.
I can't believe that guy can't blend
that picture. Nice research man.
Powerful Google. I actually
had that, uh, that poster. Oh,
imma gym at one point they say that a
chimp is 150 pound champ is supposed to
have the strength of a 500 pound man.
So what does an 800 pound gorilla?
I have the strength by God.
It's just unfathomable. Yeah.
They purchased tear you apart. Just
pull you pretty much. Pretty much.
You just have to wonder about these
researchers laying out there in the grass
with these things. It
does. Oh, stands still.
When they bluffed charge you, you cannot
move, man. You have to stand still. It's
too much for me, man. Oh well, you know,
they didn't even know the gorillas
were real until the early 19 hundreds.
It was just a legend. They, there was
a recent discovery as far as like,
uh, you know, uh,
biologists would just hear about these
things that lived in the jungles,
but they didn't have any real
evidence of mountain gorillas until,
I think it was like 19,
10 or something like that.
And they finally started seeing
them and taking photographs of them.
Do you imagine the first person to stumble
across a fucking gorilla and realize
that's a real thing? Blow your mind,
man. A hundred years ago he said,
those guys in those days,
they were into trophy hunting and they
probably just shoot the hell out of these
things. They're, they're pretty
peaceful from what I understand. I mean,
they let you alone.
Yeah.
There's a lot of trophy hunters now
reclusive and all that. You know,
what was really amazing to me, why
is that? The chimpanzees, uh, there,
they commit murder and rape and the
different tribes actually hunt each other
and they're cannibals. They're not the
cute little things that you, uh, they're,
they're nasty little guys.
That's another thing about chimps.
They didn't find out until the
90s that they even ate meat. Yeah.
They're omnivores. Just pretty much,
well, like I said, 98% of our, uh,
of our DNA because that's the crazy
thing about guerrilla sit there.
Not Gorillas are huge, enormous, muscular,
be super aggressive, giant
canines, the sprouts and shit,
bamboo, bamboo. Why they had that
enzyme where they can process,
uh, the, the cellulose, one thing
that differentiates us from,
let's say a lot of other, uh,
let's say like a sheep cattle,
but even gorillas, they have a digestive
enzyme that breaks down cellulose.
Human beings do not.
That's why a lot of people that go into
veganism and tried to do all raw food
diets don't do so well.
You can,
a human beings cannot process cellulose.
So all the nutrients that are bound and
the cellulose fiber cannot be
absorbed or assimilated into the body.
So we have to do things like cook food.
You know,
like Broccoli for example,
is completely on digestible,
but yet you see it in every salad bar
really. So when you eat broccoli raw,
it's as you're just doing nothing,
you're not getting much. It becomes
a digestive irritant. Really.
Same thing with call a fire. That's
why they should be cooked or steamed.
So you know, to break down the
cellulose or you can juice them.
The high speed juicing process,
you take the cellulose out of there and
then you get the nutrients and so forth.
Do you cold press juice?
You ever, you ever have cold
press juice? Well, you know,
guys, I'm on the road. I don't have
kitchen implements and so forth,
but for sure I would if you know,
if, uh, if I had a permanent set up.
Yeah,
there's a company near me that the cells
cold pressed juices and cod are so good
and they're, I mean, this company, they
have like cabbage and all these W. I mean,
they don't taste the best,
but God damn,
you just feel the nutrients when you drink
it. It's like your body just goes yes.
You know, like it does it a little
Diego Sanchez. Yes. Cartwheel.
And when you drink it, yeah.
Guy's a character. You,
I worked with them down at the university
to Jujitsu. What a, what a great,
well you got him in probably with the
best shape of his life when he fought Bj
Penn for the title
amazing shape. I mean Bj is an
incredible fighter. Let's face it.
His skill set is just like amazing.
And uh,
the only thing that was probably keeping
Diego and his feet in that fight was
the fact that he was just
in such a superb shape.
It would have been more merciful if he
wouldn't have been at shape because then
he could have just got knocked out.
I mean it,
it was really bad that cuts
and so forth that he, he got,
well the cut is what stopped it and that
was a big hit. It was just awful. Man.
His face was really laid open.
It was very sad.
Yeah.
He got caught early in that fight too.
He got hurt like moments into the first
with a right hand and then it's just,
I don't know.
I mean even if he wasn't in shape,
Diego's just got such an incredible will.
I mean, I don't think I ever seen, man,
I don't think I've ever seen a
guy with a wheel that strong.
I've never seen a guy able to push
himself to such an nth degree.
A picture of him.
He looked fantastic in that fight to get,
it doesn't look like that now.
Oh No.
Well maybe trying a little bit different
way or he just doesn't look as muscular
as strong. You know, he's, uh,
he's, he's, he's smaller now.
I think maybe he's sacrificed a little
bit of a muscle mass for maybe more
cardio,
but he's also fluctuated back and forth
now more like he's done a few fights at
one 17, like with Jake Ellenberger,
Martin Kampmann and then he's,
he's gone down to 55 and
he goes back and forth.
He actually said that
before his last fight,
he ate some bad beef tar
tar and got sick. And, uh,
that he had like some sort of
a food poisoning that sapped
him of his, uh, his, uh,
strength, um, before the miles
jury fight his last fight.
I thought that was crazy that
he would eat beef tar tar like,
like right before he fought like a
major UFC fight without knowing like the
source of things. You ate it at like
a hotel, you know, he was in Vegas,
well been a long time
wrestling competitor.
I arrested all through the sixties and
seventies and then later I got into
Brazilian Jujitsu.
I was very animate about never
eating anything different,
you know, when it came within
a day or so with the fight.
So I would never experiment or eat
anything unusual or no way, ma'am.
Yeah, I think I would think Diego
would. I think it was Dallas. Actually.
None of the think about it though. I
don't think it wasn't Vegas, but you know,
I was shocked that he would do
that. Eat Beef Tartar. I mean,
that's a risky thing to eat too.
Raw beef.
Well, he just don't know
these hotels. I mean,
what you're going to get and these
restaurants and so forth. Uh,
usually when I travel, I try to
use air BNB, air BNB, airbnb.
What's that? Uh, it's a website where
you can rent a little apartments or,
or even a little cottages and houses and
they're all over the world and bed and
breakfasts and breakfast B
and B. Dot com. Fantastic. Uh,
uh, uh, so much cheaper than hotels.
Plus you don't have to go broke going
out to dinner all the time in restaurants
and so forth because usually these
places have stoves or ovens and you know,
you can cook. Sometimes you will clock
out and have a blender or something,
you know, and I mean,
wow, it's really good.
You can buy your stuff and bring it back.
Oh,
that's nice.
So you go and go to a grocery store
that's got to make a huge difference when
you're traveling.
Like I do. Yeah, that's tricky
right out a lot. But, uh,
it now what they kind of died
I have is really not that hard.
A lot of times I'll just go to
grocery stores and so forth and, and,
and by the food and bring it
back. I find, believe it or not,
in Europe and even Russia.
I was just in Russia not too long ago.
Uh, the food is superior to what we
have in the United States. Really. Uh,
they don't have agribusiness there.
You know,
if you go into an average
supermarket in the United States,
you'll see all the fruit.
It's perfect.
It's all waxy and shiny and everything's
lined up. And then of course,
unless you go into it like
an organic place, you know,
like whole foods or something.
But if you're not buying
organic produce, you know,
the produce always looks a uniform.
It's a pretty and but it tastes
kind of like cardboard in Europe.
It looks like they just pick the apples
off someone out of someone's backyard.
I mean sometimes they'll have like holes
and they're irregular shaped and I mean
it just looks like, you know, like fruit,
you pick off a tree and
absolutely delicious.
You go down the aisle of a US supermarket,
let's just take the
cereal aisle for example.
You might have like 80 choices there.
You might have like five or six people
don't overeat like we do here in the
states. And the food is much
simpler but really delicious.
It's not hard to feed yourself.
And your,
so the vegetables are closer to like,
like heirloom tomatoes.
That's a type of thing and you
can taste the difference. Boy,
have you ever had folks who've
never had an heirloom tomatoes?
The tomatoes that we have in stores today?
Um,
a lot of times what you're getting is
these genetically modified tomatoes that
are surviving for periods of time since
they've been picked to the time that you
eat them. They can last weeks and
weeks and weeks, which is not normal.
I grow tomatoes and if I take one of my
tomatoes and I pick it and then I put it
on my counter in a couple of days, it
starts getting funky. That's right.
You want to eat it quick, you want
to pick it and eat it within days.
But these store bought tomatoes that
you're getting, you know where the,
that have been modified. They're
pale and they're hard and they like,
they can take a beating, a
regular tomatoes, that kind
of a mushy fruit. It does.
They don't really,
they don't stay from that long.
A lot of the nutrients and so
forth, there's just not there. Yeah,
they're grounded
nutritionally depleted soil.
They're harvested early so that
they have a longer shelf life.
They're genetically modified. And I
like apples for example, you know,
they had these storage
apples and you know,
people are eating apples
during the winter and so forth.
But I mean these things
are like really old.
I mean they'd been around in storage,
cold storage.
They're not getting the nutrients like
they could if they were eating in season.
Yeah. I've started over
the last couple of years,
started growing my own food and
growing my own food and my own eggs.
That's a big one. I have my own chickens
and uh, I mean these chickens are pets.
Like my, my three year old daughter
picks him up and she can carry them.
I mean their pets and they
run around the yard. They,
the grass and worms and the food,
they table scraps too,
which is great because food that,
you know,
we'd necessarily might not eat,
you know, you scrape a plate off.
It doesn't have to look pretty, you
know, like leftovers. You know, W we,
we do eat leftovers and we will see them
and put them back in the frigerator.
But like the stuff that's just sort of
like a little bit left on your plate,
we'll just take a little bit of
that like from everybody's plate,
put it on a plate, put it out there
for the chickens. They go nuts for it.
But you know, we don't feed them
chicken of course, but you know,
we'll feed them beef and we'll feed
them vegetables and you know, they'll,
they'll eat all sorts of different things.
It was like, yeah, let Gracie's
farm Antares op was, you know,
he lived up in the hills and he had his
own farm and he had his own Checketts
that were free range. They would bring
the eggs in. He had his own herd of cows.
They're just grass fed. He would milk
those cows every day from the raw.
He used to big me. He knew I liked milk.
You bring me a picture. So frothy from,
for the cows teat set it on
the table for me to drink.
That would be my breakfast.
A liter of raw cow milk. Wow.
He would make cheese from that milk,
his own brand of cheese with no
salt or anything. Just like a,
a fresh non age type cheese. Uh,
he would go down to the pond.
He had his big spring fed pond where
he would fish catch the fish for that
night. Uh, vegetables were grown
in a garden. Uh, he, you know,
you hear about these ass drinks, you
know, most of them are just sugar water,
just frozen sugar water.
[inaudible] he buy in the supermarket.
Yeah, I saw he's a berry, a
Brazilian bury the squat on Ah,
that has this sort of, uh, it's, it's
kind of a stimulant effect to it.
Streamline, uh, uh, high and all
sorts of nutrients and so forth.
Antioxidants, it taste really bitter.
It's not a, it's not a sweet fruit.
He would pick the sie off the tree and
come in and actually literally juice as I
write there for, excuse me, fresh on
the spot. It was amazing, man. You know,
there's coconuts. It was these little
tiny bananas he would get. I mean,
he was basically living off off the
land, you know, it was really cool.
I think the only thing they would buy,
they would have rice
and stuff occasionally,
but for the most part he was just living
off the food that he produced on his
farm. I want to do that self sufficient,
man. That's my ultimate goal. I mean,
I'm slowly working my way towards that
by growing a bunch of food around the
house. But it's, that's,
that's the solution mean I
thought about it, I was like,
everybody wants all these things.
Everybody wants, I want a boat. You know,
I want a vacation home. I
wanted this. And I'm like,
how many people that have money ever
raise their own food? No one ever says,
Hey,
I'm going to take this money and I'm
going to invest in a patch of land and in
soil and farming tools
and the, you know, the,
the heirloom seeds and I'm going to grow
my own food. Nobody fucking does that.
It's, it's a weird thing. People's
priorities are very skewed, very skewed,
and said, well, you know, like with my own
example, I mean I wasn't always this way,
but uh, I, everything I own
is in one 65 liter, beck,
one 65 liter bags in the trunk of the car.
How big is 65 liters?
It's about maybe like 14 inches
high by about 28 inches long.
Wow. And that's it. It wasn't always that
way. Of course, I had the four story,
Brad Stone House it filet and
the, you know, Jim and the,
the first Brazilian Jujitsu Academy in
the, the eastern seaboard Max her size.
Right. Matricide. Even beforehand. I
heard about that place back in the day.
But you are one of the first American
black belts. I was one of the,
I don't know what the ranking,
but it's certainly one of the early one.
What year did you get your black belt?
2000 from Helson Gracie, Hawaii. And then,
um, I was voice Gracie's, uh,
training a trainer for his first.
So you got your black belt when
you and your late forties? Uh, I,
I did 48 years old.
I'm 61 now.
So what was 2000 so it was what, 58. Wow.
So when you were training down at a
elios place, you were still brown belt?
I was a purple belt. Purple Belt. Wow. And
it was, you get invited to go down there?
I was with voice as his trainer.
I was trying to prep him for the village.
He fight.
Oh,
so you're a strength and conditioning
coach does this conditioning coach and a,
I was pretty close with voice.
Uh,
his wife used to actually be my kid's
babysitter and I knew her when she was
going to medical school.
Maryann,
she also taught aerobics and was one
of my exes has instructors and very
knowledgeable woman when it came to
exercise and fitness and things. And uh,
she was actually going to get her degree
in pediatric medicine and a pediatric
pediatric Hodiak. She
was a foot doctor. Oh,
podiatry. Yeah. Podiatry. And then, uh, I,
I used to bring hoists and he would stay
with me for a prolonged period of time.
He'd stayed with me for, I forget how many
weeks. It was a really long time. And,
uh, you know, my wife and
I were older and you know,
we have this young Brazilian kid,
what are you going to do with this guy?
So I said, Marianne, she was really
pretty girl, you know, I said, hey,
what'd you just take him out? I mean, it
just do something, anything, you know.
So she was doing it basically as a favor,
you know, a little bit under protest,
you know. But she, she, she took her out
and show it and if they fell in love, oh,
it was awesome man. I mean
it was so cool, you know?
Then he was supposed to go back to
California and we had a huge blizzard
affiliate. All the airport
was shut down, all this stuff.
So he stayed like this extra weight and
that was the first snow that hoist had
ever experienced.
We made a snowman together and of course
he put ads in the snow man and has a
snow man with this, with this big butcher
knife. And is it real much the snowman?
But it's so much fun. Of course he
wanted to drive my car in the store.
I was like, oh my God, fuck out of
here. Did you let him? Yeah. Well, hey,
it was horse crazy. He didn't say no
man. How'd that go? He was actually,
it's amazing driver. Very kind
of car. Was it? It was a Subaru.
A front wheel dial. Subarus are great
in the snow. Notoriously greatness now.
So yeah, no, he did great man. He
figured out how to steer into the skid.
I scared the shit out of it.
It's been fun though.
You must have been like a little kid.
That was back in the early days,
you know when things were still innocent.
When I started with the Gracies,
they were all one big happy family.
What year was this?
This is 89 I had my first
seminar. I said, Holy Shit,
this is what I've been looking for, man.
89 so you were way ahead of the curve.
Way Ahead of the curve. I had,
you know, after college wrestling,
I coached for a few years in the local
high school. I did the freestyle circuit.
But Hey,
it's a young man's sport and it's really
hard when you have a family and you're
working to actually go to a university
and train with university wrestlers and
you start missing your
timing and you know,
so I was looking for something to
replace the thrill of wrestling.
What were you doing for work then?
I was actually working in a gym.
I was a fitness director for,
uh,
at the Society Hill Club in
Philadelphia at that time.
And so I'm just looking for something,
man. I tried to come through. I try,
I try Kemp a crappy day.
I tried to Japanese style karate.
I try my hand up and we Thai, I basically
sucked at these striking arts. You know,
it just wasn't in my,
just wasn't in my genetics.
I wanted to grab and clinch it used to
really piss my instructors off cause it
was almost like, you know, an
instinctive reaction and uh,
I quickly learned that you can avoid like,
you know what,
let's take MMA and put it to a side.
I was interested purely in self
defense at that time. You know,
I always felt like somehow I missed the
boat because that was the Bruce Lee era,
right? Seventies and, and uh,
later. And I always thought, wow,
I shouldn't have been wasting
my time with wrestling.
I shouldn't have been doing like g condo
or, or you know, that it man stuff.
And uh,
I didn't realize what a good
basis wrestling really was
and the few scraps I did
get in, I found that wow, you know,
double leg take down goes a long way,
you smashed somebody, then it's kind
of takes to fight on them a little bit,
you know? And uh, but
little striking I do,
I was able to equip myself all right.
And a few scraps I had,
but I still felt like it was something
missing. There's fancy kicks and punches.
And when I saw that Gracie Jujitsu,
I said, man, I could do this,
I could really do this.
And then I saw the first Gracie in
action tape and I realized, wow, man,
this is very doable.
And so I went into it with this
whole self defense aspect in mind,
which they really emphasize
in those days. But yeah. Hey,
it was one big happy family.
The [inaudible] has had just split from
horror and when I first met him they
went with Chuck Norris as you know,
there was like a bit of a
difference of opinion or whatever.
And then after I'd been at the Gracie
Academy for a couple of years, uh, I,
I would fly from Philly.
I had a,
at that point I have my own
gym at night in 19 nine open.
Either go out for a couple of weeks at
a time with a certain budget and I would
take like a thousand dollars or whatever
and I would take lessons for $100 at
that time with Horian or
voice or Heuler or Hickson.
And I see if I got one move in that hour,
I caught up my hundred dollars move.
Cause usually there would be,
you know how it is in Jujitsu,
especially when you're blue belt,
you get really confused and you get in
these positions over and over again and
you can't quite figure out what to do.
And if they would give me the answer to
that particular problem, I would say, ah,
that was the hundred dollar move that was
worth every penny to me because that's
how into it. I was, I would go through my
thousand dollars or so, right with the,
with the private lessons.
And of course they would throw the
classes in for free since I was buying so
many privates.
And then I would go back and I had mats
in my gym and then I would just call up
all my old wrestling buddies and
there was a judo club nearby.
I would call those guys in.
And there was a Kido guys down the
street and I would just basically beat up
these poor guys.
And it didn't know what you were doing.
I had no idea I had rental guys
and knowing that any of it,
they didn't know much. It was more, you
know, Judah became very sports oriented,
but I did pick up some good stuff
from the dot. Guys delete. Oh yeah.
So good throws and so forth trips at,
but I had what they called wrestler jets,
you know, and it pretty rough,
pretty rough stuff. A Lot,
a strength, a lot of power,
just like wrestling, you know what I
mean? What did I know? And um, but I,
I got my blue Bob pretty
quick about six months,
then I got my purple belt
in about a year and a half.
I think I went through the ranks,
but then I reached the
level of my incompetence and
there I stay prep about for
about four years. What do you mean do
reach the level you're in incompetence.
I just couldn't make that
next jump to brown belt.
I'm still using too much power. Too much
strange, too much athleticism, you know,
and you know, just as supposed to be
based in technique and relaxation.
And I still didn't have that.
I can remember one time voice
got really pissed off with me.
We were in the middle of a session, you
know, and uh, I was been, what, you know,
she did it is sort of a rude,
I was kind of grabbing the g
in a rough way and you know,
wrestlers had this way of kind of
grinding heads. Sometimes you don't,
it's really pissing him off. And he says,
hey wait, this is the key. This is skin.
And then we wrestled at bay
said, wait, Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Why are you grinding your head into mind?
What,
what are you possibly
thinking to achieve with this?
And then he looked up at
the clock, he says, okay,
these next 10 minutes or going to be
the most terrifying of your life, Steve.
And I'm like, swollen gulp. You
know, I knew I was going to happen.
He had basically just wiped
the mat up with me, squeeze me,
smashed me knee and the belly and
the ribs and he wouldn't let me tap.
And he just basically thrashed me
for 10 minutes straight, nonstop.
I was just utterly exhausted. Not
Dementia, just the, the, the trauma.
I've just been thrown around by
your iPad or your hero, you know,
and who was mad at you. So there
was that emotional thing going on.
And then he says, okay, how's it feel?
Steve feels pretty bad. Darn it. I says,
man, it really does. He
says, well, you know,
that's what other people feel like
when you wrestle them. He says,
when you rested these other guys, that's
what you're doing to them. He says,
not much fun.
You're going to turn people off from
Jujitsu so you better never, ever,
I'd never been to catch you again using
all that power and strength and being so
rude. And it was like, wow, okay.
And then the next day I got the flu
because it lowered my immune system.
Wow, man, I'm telling you, and you're
asking really kicked my ass. It was,
it was rich man
flow and us.
Oh,
I was so disappointed
because he's teaching these
seminars and I couldn't go on
the couch with a fever.
Ah, man. It taught me. Yeah,
such an important message about
relaxation and you know all that.
Yeah,
I've learned that around it.
Probably purple belt to just
learn how to relax and how to,
we'll also learn how to like,
do like a real 20 minutes session.
Like how do you roll with someone for 20
minutes? If you'd just go on, Jack can't,
you can't sprint for 20 minutes
and there's days. I, you know,
I still wasn't getting it,
man. I wasn't getting it. But I,
that Beaton really made a
profound influence on me and
he did me a great service,
great service. I always liked that whole
Gracie a teaching aspect of the thing.
You know, like, like Jorge,
I know he said, you know,
it's not really a martial arts style.
It's a, it's an educational system.
It's a way of teaching Jujitsu.
Yeah. I liked her a motto, keep it
playful to, you know, Henner and,
and a here on the, the uh, they say that
all the time, keep it playful, cute,
playful, and it, you know, you, you can
protect yourself while you're doing that.
And then slowly but surely
a guy who was going to ask,
unless you're dealing with a three minute
match and you're going to have your
opportunities. And you
know, I mean I'm not
against the competition aspect of it,
but it is different.
I know Allie had told me one time that
he considered the modern day competition
to be anti Jujitsu. I thought that
was interesting statement. He says,
I would never,
I would never been able to win like one
of these modern style matches with the
points and all that.
So that wasn't my game.
He said I couldn't do much to other
people cause I was too small, too weak.
He said they,
they did it to themselves.
Did Leo do any strength and
conditioning now? Now that I know of,
I mean he did stretching and you know,
basic jujitsu conditioning stuff,
but he never really believed in weight
training or any of that. But uh, you know,
he always mentioned how weak he was,
but he did have a strength as grips
were pretty amazing even for an old man.
And of course he had this huge
Popeye type forums, you know,
so I mean it was obvious
that he definitely had some
athleticism and strength,
but he was such a lightweight guy.
There was no way he's going to
overpower anyone. Right. But have you,
have you ever read the
biography of Aci made?
The guy that taught the grace and Carlos,
uh,
I read the Japanese translation into
English and of course it definitely had a
Japanese prejudice to it,
but that guy was a pretty amazing guy.
He was a representative sent from
the code icon. She grew up Kaino,
organized all the Jujitsu clans in Japan
and was trying to come up with the one
style of Jujitsu, which he
called judo, the gentle way.
In those days there was a lot of ground
fighting, uh, throws into joint locks,
all this stuff that's illegal. And Modern
Day judo was still part of the game.
They had knee blocks.
Uh,
I actually watched a video tape
of old black and white footage.
Some of these old Japanese
masters we're doing the ex guard.
Wow. Leo told me that everything
was there when he, uh,
when Carlos Learn Jujitsu for my item,
but my Ada,
a lot of people don't know one over
thousand, no hold barred fights.
It all styles and a thousand.
That was,
how the hell do you fight a
thousand times. I don't know.
How's that even possible?
It's like that Hixon 400 old things.
Someone tried to break that down
once of how I would like to know
he did a stage fights and
Spain and England and France.
Then he came to the u s
you mean on stage? You don't
mean like staged like no, no.
You determined like they would ask people
from the audience come up and chat,
like those type of things and there
were no holds barred fights or they were
judo match. They were no hold
bar fights. Wow. They could
do anything to the guy. And uh,
he fought boxers. Uh, well he,
he he talked was one of the guys
that taught Theodore Roosevelt,
the early Judah real and
that became a part of the,
the training for a naval aviator or
army aviators during World War Two.
And a lot of the army
guys in World War II,
that Jujitsu was the basis for
the self defense in the U s army.
And then,
uh,
one of his cohorts was humiliated by
a champion wrestler from West Point.
And, uh, my ada got some
Japanese businessmen to put
up some money and then he,
he, he beat the guy that,
that beat his partner.
And then from there he emigrated to Cuba
and did all of these fights and Cuba.
I mean,
he was fighting like apparently for
money a couple of times a week he went to
Mexico and they would go to the mining
camps where these, these, you know, or,
or a lumberjack camps where we had all
these guys with a lot of money and they
would bet and sometimes he would almost
lose a match on purpose to encourage
guys to come out there and say,
I can beat this little guy.
And then he would kick their asses.
Well, it was like Charles Bronson and
hard times. Japanese version. Yeah,
Japanese version. Wow.
He was only 165 paths,
but apparently had some
devastating throws.
And his groundwork was just absolutely
superb. He was Wa and Jigger. Oh,
throw him out. It was out of Buddha.
Like you're doing these fights,
you're fighting with
no, sometimes, you know,
it's not what we represent here
at the CoCASA. He was baby coat.
AECON is the main sanctioning body
that was the main sanctioning body,
Japan in Japan at that time. And so, uh,
he kept going further and further down.
And then of course the Gracies met him,
had hap helped him get
a Japanese immigration.
Connie started the father of Carlos.
Gracie helped this, my Ada
guy get established. And uh,
in, in gratitude, he, he, uh,
he taught the, the five sons.
Uh, it was Carlos, Oswaldo, uh,
I forget the guys, but there was,
you know,
Carlos had the five brothers.
The only guy that didn't
directly get taught was Elio.
Elio learned his Jujitsu pretty
much from Carlos. He was very weak,
sickly child at the time. And, uh, uh,
they basically were doing
the Jujitsu of my Ada. Wow.
And then ll would watch his brother
teach and then it was discovered that,
wow, he's really adept. There's, you know,
he has a real knack for
teaching and doing Jujitsu.
Carlos kind of just handed the reins over
to La and then he took it and ran with
it and developed it and the
rest is pretty much history.
It's so fascinating that even to this
day the smaller guys are the more
technical guys and when you think about
the birth of Jujitsu happening from
Carlos Teaching Leo and
Leo being a small guy,
his Jujitsu became very
technical like the last year of,
see we were talking about
this when it comes up,
when the fly weights in the Bantam,
he,
so 120 535 pound fighters and I,
I've said many,
many times if you want to see excellent
technique like these are really the guys
to watch first of all because
they never get tired and too,
because when you're 125
pound guy and you're the gym,
you're not muscling
anybody around that muscle.
You got to learn to do
everything correctly.
Everything has to be proper technique.
Everything has to be perfect form.
You have a gravity and strength
disadvantage from the jump.
And so because of that you learn to do
everything absolutely correctly mean you
very rarely see like a really good light
Jujitsu guy who tries to muscle things.
They
don't try to muscle sometimes it actually
bachelors and they'll do that right up
through about purple Bob like
myself and then they get lost.
They're tech, they're the, the,
the technique begins to outstrip their
strengths at the brown and black belt
levels. The guys, everyone
is strong in good shape,
but they have incredible
technique at that level.
So if you've been basing most of your,
your winnings on athleticism
and strength and all that,
once you hit brown belt, man, I forget it.
It's not going to happen too much
anymore. Yeah. I've always said, man,
if you could get a guy like Mark Coleman
who was such a dominant wrestler in his
prime, you know, when he was
at UFC heavyweight champion,
if that guy just fell in love with
Hugh Jitsu and just was passed the card
mounting taking packs,
take an arm bars,
I mean he would've just been a fucking
beast. Bit of based. Well yeah.
Oh he was a beast. Kenny, Kevin
Randleman, all those guys.
None of them embrace Jujitsu. Nah, they
never did. It was always, you know,
well it's that restaurant mentality.
I mean, I had it, you know,
I thought I'd do everything.
Your wrestlers are pretty aggressive
guys and you know, you're,
you're very confident in yourself and
there's a tendency to think you know,
everything but smart wrestlers,
you know,
they eventually they start to lighten up
and they start to embrace the technique
of Jujitsu.
It makes it perfect combination.
It's real easy for wrestlers to just
slide right in there, man. Sure.
It's just about,
I mean that's her thing about wrestling
as opposed to Jujitsu as wrestlers are
so much more drill oriented wrestlers
like by necessity drill techniques a lot
con constant training. If you go
to any high level wrestling room,
you'll watch guys hit techniques over and
over and over and over and over again.
Whereas in Jujitsu this is like a
little bit of drilling and then okay,
if free train everybody this role and
everybody just role because it's so fun,
so just roll. So front of
just try to submit each other
that you know they don't,
they don't do the same sort of drilling
and technique based training that a lot
of wrestlers to at the highest
level wrestling on the feet.
The standup part of wrestling is just
as technical shit too in many ways.
Subtle lot of setups.
I mean it's pretty amazing.
Those guys that flow wrestling,
you ever gone to that? Right? I
love that website. Great website,
but they do a great job of explaining
that and showing how technical the
European and the Russian
wrestlers are and you know, how,
how much more they rely on
those techniques and the
subtle varieties of their,
their exchanges and their entrances
into techniques. I really liked that.
I liked the emphasizing that aspect of
the wrestling cause a lot of people don't
know what it is. You see big, strong
guys trying to overpower each other.
You don't understand this.
It's like there's so many different
moves that are being exchanged at a rapid
pace. And you know, so many
tax centers. Yeah. Faints.
And I had the privilege of working
with five times of Ukrainian national
wrestling champion,
Andre Brenner.
He used to come up to my school in
Philadelphia all the time and wow. The
guys showed me so much
technical wrestling. And then
one of my students was uh,
uh, your Sushi Miyaki who was one of the
judges for pride. He was a fourth don,
a black belt in judo from the critical on.
But he was also three time world
Greco Roman wrestling champion. Wow.
And he was working for a Japanese import
company in Philly, came into our school.
God was, you know, the big
thick coke bottle glasses.
Just this kind of silly little grand,
really polite. He's bowing a lot.
He spoke almost no English and you know,
so he went in to train with us.
So we get McGee, you know,
he puts, he puts on the wipe
out, you know? No, no foss.
Next thing I know he's launching dudes,
man.
Oh my God.
What a sleeper wipe out man.
I mean,
and you had no idea what
his background was doing.
Like sagging Auggie's from the knees
and throwing guys, man. It's like wow.
So we finally get the guy to write his
name for us so we could Google them.
And then what year was this?
This is like 95 [inaudible] 95 no,
there was like some sort of an internet
or some kind of internet cause I,
I was completely non tech. I didn't
even have a laptop in those days. Joe.
I didn't even have a cell phone
back at 95 so I don't know.
What am I students did whatever
that you do on the, on,
on a computer and looked him up and
found him. And then we said, Holy Shit,
you've got a gym.
This guy is unbelievable man.
And we were shocked. It was like three
times. Well, Greco Roman, he was a,
uh,
an Olympian and the Atlanta Olympics.
Wow. He plays this just try to
out of the metal round. Yeah.
He just wanted us to
train and he was saying,
I guess he had heard
about Brazilian Jiu Jitsu,
want to try it out. And uh, he
went through the rags fit fast man.
I actually took him the first professional
grappling tournament was the pro am
event out of South Carolina.
Do you remember this?
There was a couple of guys that put it
on a couple of hundred entrepreneurs.
A man,
I'm terrible for these dates.
Managed really put me on
the spot with these dates.
Uh, but buzz pre a hoists
and Willie g, right.
That was 98 was hoists and well,
easy when you went down to Brazil,
I think it was, yeah, it was pray,
pray. And I was probably, oh, I got it.
Oh,
maybe it was 2000 after 2000
you say she in this thing,
it took second place. It gets really
good black belts at that time.
I wish I could remember something that
I know heuler fought. Uh, there was,
it was like a WHO's who of wow.
Grappling Solow fought. He uh,
he fought this catch wrestler guy.
No kidding. It was real interesting.
It was like a mixed grappling style,
but it's called the pro am it was
like the first professional level type
grappling.
Yeah,
I remember it vaguely now. I remember
it vaguely now, but I was still,
I was really, I started in 96. I started,
I took my first class at
Hickson's and then um,
Hickson's was pretty far down.
It was on Pico
and I found that Carlson
had a place on Hawthorne,
which is like really close to where I
was working. So, uh, I went to cross,
to me it was a white belt
was like Gracie is Gracie.
Yeah, for sure. I mean, and I
came in right when
[inaudible] was fighting.
John Hess with Vito was like 18 years
old and they were calling him victor
Gracie. It wasn't Vietor they
put a k in there. I don't,
you know, I don't know why.
What happened? They changed his
name. I don't know what happened,
but it was Victor Gracie,
Victor Carlson was trying to uh,
adopt him or was treating
him like he was his son.
And so he's taking on the name Gracie.
Cause the Gracie name was huge back then,
96, a couple of years after the
ultimate fighting championship.
Everybody wanted to train with him.
Everybody wanted to be a grace.
Yeah.
Yeah. And um, uh,
I got a chance to see a
Mario Sperry was down there.
Marillo booster mom
was training back then.
Sergio Colin like all these black belts
from Brazil. Carlos by Hato was there.
They were the guys man
laid the foundations here in America.
You know,
I just got so lucky I came in and I got
to watch that all happen right during
the extreme fighting days.
Remember that when John Perretti was
putting on those extreme fighting
challenges and half Gracie was
there and you know, half grace,
he was fighting those. Remember
those, those, that was the
back of the day. That was
back in the day, man. Well,
a lot of people don't realize
you're your athletic prowess either.
I mean a lot of your listeners have no
clue. I'm always shocked when I say, well,
Joe is like world class athlete man.
People always say really?
It says, yeah, he's not just a television
host or comedian or an actor. He says,
this guy can rumble,
man,
I'll never forget when you show me that
spinning back kick and the banana bags
into your garage. I mean there
were 200 pound bags, Joe,
you were bending those things in half
my ribs hurt just watching you do that
man.
So a lot of people don't realize your
pedigree and Jujitsu and submission,
wrestling and kickboxing to a man.
So
well, I've been obsessed with
it my whole life. You know,
the only thing that's been fucking with
me lately is I haven't really been able
to roll hard for the last year.
I've only rolled a little once over the
last year I had a bulging disc in my
back, actually my neck and a, I started
doing this thing called Regena keen.
I did a bunch of different
therapies for it, uh,
but I was really worried about pursuing
Jujitsu pass this because I started
getting numbness in my fingers and uh,
I had heard a lot of horror stories
and I'm friends with boss route and of
course and bus route and has had a
pretty bad neck injury that he's had two
surgeries on.
And he actually just started going and
doing Regena keen at the same place where
I've had it done.
And so I went through a bunch of
different procedures and after a year of
different therapies, like, um,
uh, I did, uh, prolo ozone,
which is prolotherapy with ozone,
which stimulates healing. And, uh,
I did a lot of thing like really hardcore
deep tissue massage and a soft tissue
manipulation there with Ralf.
Do you, do you do any of that?
I was actually Ralf by Ida Rolf
Son. Whoa. They guy, you know,
she invented rolfing out of frustration
because her son went through that polio
epidemic of the 50s.
It was all twisted up,
this poor kid and she took
him to specialist after
specialist and just that she
had a phd in biochemistry is very
intelligent one and a sheer frustration.
She just started molding the boy herself
and came up with their ideas of rolfing
and then began to teach other people
the postural integration techniques.
I was wrought by that point.
Wow,
that's amazing.
He was an amazing role for, and then I
had a woman in Philadelphia, Linda grace,
fantastic. One of the professors at
the Rolf Institute, they, they, they,
they go and teach for a
while and they, they uh, they
revolve in and out. You know,
it's not always the same
professors at the Rolf Institute,
but this woman saved my own
life and my Jujitsu career,
I had some pretty horrific injuries.
No one ever said that playing combat
sports is healthy man. No Man.
I had this conversation today with
the doctor because uh, I've been a,
I have some photos of it then
I'm going to put up on Instagram,
but I'll show them to you with, with this
process is, but it's pretty fascinating.
What they do is they take
your blood and they, um,
this is me lying on this table with all
these needles in my back and then those
little tubes on the end of the needles,
that's where they pumped this serum in.
I put all these on Instagram
later so you guys can see them.
And what it is is you,
they take your blood and the blood is
placed in a centrifuge and it spun around
and it's heated.
And somehow we're another,
during this process, like it treats your
body, treats the blood, like the blood,
the blood reacts as if it's having,
like if there's a fever.
And so it generates this intense anti
inflammatory response and this yellow
fluid becomes the most potent
antiinflammatory medication known to man.
And it's produced by your own blood,
which is really amazing.
So they pull this yellow serum out and
then they inject it directly into the
injured areas with dramatic results
around antiflammatory. Yes. You know,
we had talked about supplements earlier,
right?
And I, uh, I used to be quite
the supplement hound, you know,
anywhere between two 50 to $300 a
month as spending it supplements.
And I quickly realized that I was actually
undermining my body's ability to make
its own anti inflammatories.
Your body went as being fed
properly and you die. You know,
your digestion isn't in order and you're
assimilating the nutrients that you
need from your diet.
You make your own anti-inflammatories
and you do not need to be taking a lot of
extra nutrients. If anything, it
throws you completely out of balance.
Well,
I'm sure that your body can make anti
inflammatory responses to injuries,
but nothing like this. I mean,
your body is making it this,
but what you're using your own body's,
yeah.
So it's different than taking
this up. Well, it's also,
they're directly injecting it into the,
this guy doctor Peter welling is a
spinal surgeon in Dusseldorf, Germany.
And he's the one who
figured this out. Um, it's,
he is his twos two year
study of osteoarthritis of
the knee that's published in
the medical journal Journal,
osteoarthritis and cartilage,
which a started a lot of all this off
and got a lot of people invested in this,
uh,
this procedure and they figured it out
in Germany and like 2003 and the United
States has really been hampered is a
lot of this research because of all the
shit that went down with
stem cell research. The
religious right was, you know,
really putting the brakes on
any sort of stem cell research.
And they were connecting
stem cell research with fetal
tissue and aborted babies
and people are going to abort
babies just to get the fetal tissue.
There was so much fucking craziness.
And this,
this thing that they do,
the, the way that it defer,
it differentiates between play
platelet rich plasma, which is a,
what a lot of people think of when they
think of like blood spinning with this
is it's, it's a little bit
more potent. And I'm going
to, I'll, I would butcher it.
So if anybody's interested in
it, read about it online. Uh,
they call it Ortho keen in Germany and
it's called Regina keen in America,
but they do it in Santa Monica now.
It's done in Vegas and Dallas and
they're doing it all over the place with
miraculous results for athletes.
There's a lot of athletes that have,
well all these guys are,
we're flying to Germany.
Like Kobe Bryant was flying to
Germany. Um, uh, what is his name? Um,
Peyton manning at two neck surgeries
is ready to retire from football.
Went and got orthokine in Germany
and boom, playing better football.
That I was pretty amazing. Those NFL guys.
Hey, can we take a brief break? Sure.
I just need to hit the, uh, hit
the head. Go ahead. Go ahead man.
That awesome coffee gave me just listen
man, it takes a while to get us to,
I got that old man bladder going on.
Don't worry about it, dude. I'll, uh,
I got a lot of shit to shit to
talk about and let people know. Um,
anybody who's interested
in that, uh, the place,
if you're anywhere near Santa Monica.
Um,
the guy that I go to a for this Regina
king thing and have no financial just to
in the interest of full disclosure is no,
I have no financial interest in
this whatsoever. Um, his, uh,
his name is doctor Ben
[inaudible]. Uh, and uh,
he does it out of a place called lifespan
medicine that is in Santa Monica and
it's incredible stuff.
And it's also the beautiful thing about
it is you don't have to worry about your
body rejecting it. This is all something
that your body naturally produces.
So if you're interested,
um,
just run a Google search on it and find
out if there's a place anywhere near you
that, uh, that has this. But for me,
I've had amazing results with this.
Um, and then, uh, for, from that and
the rolfing and all these other, uh,
different procedures that
I've tried out of all of them,
the Regena keen has had the most dramatic
responses because it's pretty dramatic
and pretty quickly. Um,
I've also found that, uh,
if you have any joint pain
people out there with joint pain,
a big one for me has been fish oil.
Fish oil is really incredible,
anti inflammatory properties to it.
Uh,
and I have a friend
who's a carpenter and he,
he's told me that through taking fish oil,
like used to get like really sore knees
and elbows after long day at work,
just completely eradicated a
lot of that stuff. Um, I take,
I take pretty high dose fish oils.
I mean there's pros and cons and people
will argue that, uh, I take 10 a day,
I take 10 pills a day,
10,000 milligrams.
And some people say that's overdoing it
and probably Steve would say it's over
doing it. I Dunno. But I
work out like a madman.
And for me it has a huge
difference between when I take it.
And when I don't take it, I
just feel like, uh, I have
less, less joint soreness,
which is a really important for me. He,
I, you know, I'll, I would try what,
what you're doing, but I eat like
a fucking a mad man. And I just,
I don't see myself eating only a,
a vegetable meal and then a meat meal.
I eat like a fucking pig
dude. I Dunno. I always have,
I eat less, um, bad things.
Like, uh, I've, I've,
I eat very little sugar at
this point in my life. Um,
I will reward myself every now and then
with like some ice cream or a treat.
But for the most part, I get
all my sweets from fruits. I,
I very rarely indulge in any show.
Like somebody offers me
candy or something like that,
unless there's pot in it
all, you know, pop candy.
Yeah. I'm not a, I'm not really into
sugar myself, other than eating fruit.
You know, some people say, well, how
about the fructose? But they forget that,
you know, it's all bound with fiber push
up to this thing. And uh, there we go.
And it slows down the digestion so that
you're not getting this big sugar rush
or anything when you're
eating raw natural fruit.
Well, that's part of what's going on with
this bulletproof coffee idea. The idea,
which was a, apparently it was
originally invented by Robb Wolf on,
or if you know rob banks with a Paleo guy.
Yeah,
he was the guy who created
an Dave Asprey's guy. I've
sort of made it popular,
but a lot of it because being on the show,
but the grass fed butter and MCT oil
is what slows down the digestion of the
caffeine because it's blended up
together with the coffee that it just,
because when I drank, I like black coffee,
I like to drink black coffee. But man,
the difference in like the bang,
well bang,
there's a big difference in the spike
and crash with that as opposed to this
stuff,
which is like a slow burn.
And that's also the same
thing with eating fructose,
which you get from an
apple or from an orange.
It's like you're getting it in
a natural way and it's also,
it's sort of a natural reward system.
Your body is getting this
sweetness because you're,
you're ingesting all these nutrients.
Like your body's letting you know, Ooh,
you feel that mouth pleasure,
good, keep eating something stupid.
We need all that stuff. You need the
vitamin C, we need the fiber, we need the,
you know,
it's all good
energy,
good,
good for your body as opposed to this
weird thing that we've invented where we
figured out how to process sugar and pull
it out of all these fruits and pull it
out a corn and to just shoot it right
into your fucking bloodstream. I mean,
when you're eating that high fructose
corn syrup means your body doesn't know
what the fuck you're doing. Like what
is this? How are you getting this ever?
Never before in the history of man,
whether these type of Franken foods,
but I mean even sugar cane
where white folks, I mean,
have you ever actually eaten sugar yet?
I have when I lived in Florida.
All different experiences.
Delicious. Yeah,
but I mean you don't get that rush
because it's what's a fruit? It's,
it's bound up with all the other nutrients
and fibers and so forth that you get
in a whole food as as opposed
to a fractionated food. Yeah.
When I lived in Florida, me and my
friends used to cut sugar cane down.
Whether there was like a sugar cane field
near our house that was a university
of Florida in Gainesville.
They had these,
I don't know why they had
sugarcane just growing there,
but it wasn't like we were stealing it
from anybody. It was just growing there.
So we'd go and we'd cut it down.
We just eat it.
And I guess it's not a fruit
technically cause a fruit, you know,
it's something that grows on a plant
and you pluck it off the plant.
I get tomatoes, grass, I believe
maybe. Is that what it is? Yeah,
I think it's a grass. Like tomato
is technically a fruit, right?
Isn't that how it goes?
Like it's considered a
vegetable agriculturally is
considered an export belief.
It is a fruit. Like how it's taxed.
I think they consider it a vegetable,
but it's a, it's a fruit.
But uh, you know, the, the,
the Diet, I mean man seems to be
able to adapt to any number of dies.
I don't know whether the,
if I heard this guy western price
that went around the world, uh,
he was looking at indigenous people.
This was the time earlier,
the 19 hundreds when there was indigenous
people still around and he was looking
for signs of health. He
was a dentist. So you know,
tooth health is a very good indicator
of a person's overall health.
If you have rotten teeth, your
general health is pretty poor. I mean,
they've even like gum disease to heart
problems and all that kind of stuff.
So he went all of the world.
He was looking at every
type of population possible.
Uh, the annual ad, you know,
the Polynesians, uh, you
know, these different places.
And he came to the conclusion that man is,
is a very adaptable creature.
There's any number of diets that a human
being can thrive on quite healthfully.
But the thing that seemed to be
commonplace to all of these people was the
purity of the food,
the naturalists of the food,
the freshness of the food and the
lack of stress in their diets.
And of course the exposure to
sunlight and vitamin D and so forth.
And I mean in his estimation,
the most magnificent of all
the populations he studied
where the Polynesians who
were living primarily
on a starch based diet,
Taro and fish and coconut.
You were the first person to also
set me hip to the idea of um,
Sun tanning for conditioning
that suntanning the vitamin D levels
get raised in your body and that,
you know, like when George Saint Pierre
would fight with a Tan, that there's,
that it's not for vanity
like, no, no, not at all.
It's uh,
the,
the tanning salons have gotten a bad
rap because people go in there and bake
themselves just like people bake
themselves into the regular sun.
But if you go in with the idea
of not going for the Tan per se,
but to convert vitamin D in the skin,
even if you're in a place
like Iceland for example,
where you don't even get
son half of the year,
your body makes its own natural vitamin
D and You just go in for a few minutes,
maybe four times a month, and you, your
body will make all the vitamin D you need.
It's a very anabolic, a nutrient. Uh,
it's absolutely essential for immunity
and a muscular growth and recovery.
And it's really important.
I had no idea that athletes actually
would tan just to raise their natural
levels of vitamin D and to aid
in their conditioning though
a lot of people don't even know about it.
But a vitamin D actually even has kind
of a steroid like effect on your body,
you know?
But he's very animal
d three, right? Three is
the big one. Yeah. Yeah.
We had doctor Rhonda Patrick on who is
just a brilliant found my fitness has her
name on, on Twitter. And we're having
around again soon, fascinating,
fascinating woman who is just really
brilliant and knows a tremendous amount
about the human body.
And it's just a great resource for us
to be able to ask her questions about,
you know, what does this and why does
that work and what is this about?
How did Carlos Gracie, like he was
the one who invented the Gracie Diet,
these common detory foods.
And how did he figure that out?
Uh, well, you know,
there was another Brazilian writer is
that talked a lot about food combining.
I actually read a translation of his
book and, uh, there was a lot of food,
good binding people at the time.
It was fairly well known back
in the early 19 hundreds.
This doctor John Toda and I
told you about, he wrote a
book toxemia explained. Uh,
but there was also a doctor Herbert
m Sheldon who wrote, uh, uh,
food combining made easy. It was fairly
common knowledge until a lot of the,
uh, nature paths and, and, and, uh,
alternative medical
people back in the day.
This is at a crossroads where the medical
establishment was beginning to take
over and they were in cahoots with
the big pharmaceutical industry.
And they, this is at
the time when the, the,
the drug companies were really beginning
to develop a lot of vaccines and drugs.
And that's when the western medical model
was all going towards the drug side.
And they, they, the, uh, the,
the chiropractors are getting pushed
out and alternative people were being
pushed out, osteopathy, uh, you
know, nature paths and so forth.
But, uh, you know, I've,
I've done a lot of reading
and research on my own and uh,
I I've pretty much pulled away
from western medical model and uh,
I tried to do things as natural as I can,
haven't been to a doctor
Joe and probably about 40.
So you don't ever get your blood work,
Tom,
you just go based on how you
feel and if you don't feel good,
what do you do about it?
Like I fast. Really? Yeah.
Your body, you don't feel good.
You fast.
Yeah.
Funeral like shit. I'm like, Oh man, I
feel like shit. I'm just not going to eat
anything. Well I see it in
a fasting state. Your body,
it goes to the morbid disease
tissues in the body in its wisdom.
It doesn't go to muscle. Yeah. Whoa.
Your body is very wise.
So when you're not feeling well,
it's usually digestive system related
in some way and putting more food in
burdening your body. People don't realize
just what a burden digestion really is.
It takes a lot out of you to digest food.
Is that why people that have a lower
caloric diets are people that eat less
generally live longer?
Well, for sure, I mean, and
and many animal studies,
they found that by systematically under
feeding animals pro prolonging their
lives a really,
really long time.
You know, Rhonda Patrick,
who had just mentioned,
one of the things that she brought up
was a study where they showed that it's,
it's actually a genetic transference
that people who have survived through
famine,
their children actually live longer.
Like the children of people who
have had like less calories,
they're their children actually have
longer life spans. It's fascinating.
Well, if you look at animal
husbandry, you can your prize bull,
your price stallion.
You know, your stud dog,
they have relatively short life spans,
big muscular bull. You know, they,
they feed these animals that
they built a lot of mass.
They did not live very long at all.
It's because your system gets over taxed
to maintain all that muscle will become
innovated. The, the, the, the, you know,
you only have a finite amount
of energy and it, it gets taxed.
You know,
that's a big debate.
The amount of muscle you should
have as a martial artist.
That's a huge issue that comes up a lot.
Um,
it comes up a lot in my own commentary
because I find it fascinating.
There's certain guys like the guys
like the Hector Lombard's or the Tyron
Woodley's,
he's really muscular,
like abnormally muscular guys who were
fucking hell on wheels for a few minutes,
but they can't maintain like
a guy like say you know,
like a Diego Sanchez,
the guy who was known for having fantastic
director but Diego's worn a lot of
guys out in that third round.
The third round is where Diego is the
scariest motherfucker on earth cause he's
just as fresh as he wasn't the first.
Like look at Jake Ellenberger
who has a natural welterweight,
brutal knockout puncher.
Couldn't put Diego away by the time third
round came along, Diego's on his back,
pounded on him when, when
the last bell rang, you know,
and that a lot of that can be attributed
to his ability to keep up that same
pace. That ruthless pace
doesn't have a lot of muscle.
Well, a lot of it has to do with the type
of nervous system you're born with or
whether it's an efficient nervous system
or maybe not so efficient you, uh,
you, uh, they call it
neurological efficiency.
Guys with neurological efficiency are
able to use a lot of their muscle fiber
all at once.
So there high power guys and guys that
don't have neurological efficiency,
they usually have a high
anaerobic endurance level.
They just can go and go and go
at a fairly high percentage.
No. Fascinating. Like less efficient.
Yeah. So they have less power.
They have less power, but they can
go a hoist is a perfect example.
The guy hit unbelievable endurance,
but he, he, you know, he,
he didn't have a lot of fast twitch
muscle fiber. He, he was not a power guy.
And that's not something that
you can change is it is like,
can you take a guy that's an inborn thing?
So a guy like, uh, you know, like, uh,
Kevin Randleman never going to be a
triathlete. Never, never, never, never.
Just like most guys are never going
to beat Kevin Randleman, you know,
and all this idea that you can do Olympic
lifting and two selective recruitment
of muscle fiber. That's, that's
a lot of nonsense man. I,
I've been in this game for a long
time, man. I've never seen that mean.
Never seen someone who's like ectomorphic
sort of split massively to make you
more explosive on the mat.
It's, it's a, it's a big
mistake. It doesn't do anything.
Meaning must improve it.
And so any strange ready,
no matter how God awful is going
to improve, especially beginners.
But as you become more advanced,
man, that explosive weight training,
it does more harm than good.
Take it from two guys at 61.
Is that every injury and
the book, have you had, um,
if you had disc injuries, have you ever,
I have. What have you done to fix those?
Uh, I did a lot of inversion
training. Uh, you know,
I used to hang upside down. I
do that. I liked that a lot.
Of course my role for helped me a lot.
I've had acupuncture to release some
of that tension in the muscle. Uh, I,
I've done some kind of, uh, uh,
other interesting stuff. I, uh,
I believe in the power of the
subconscious mind to heal the body.
I do a lot of visualization and prayer
and literally a image myself getting
better.
I believe that your,
your mind and your subconscious mind is
in control of every cell in the body.
And that if you can,
uh,
get rid of any disbeliefs you,
your,
your higher mind can actually
influence healing in your body.
Wow. That's super unscientific as fans
you to talk about. Well, you know,
as you're fairly scientific guy,
there's a lot we don't know if there's
a very interesting book out right now.
I would really encourage your readers
or your listeners to check it out.
It's called the healing code.
They talk a lot about how healing code,
the healing co wrote that. Do you
know, uh, let me see. Johnson,
a guy by the name of John,
there was an MD and a phd.
They actually wrote the book and they
talk about it in, in the relationship.
Do it like physics and, and, and, and,
and how belief systems
absolutely, uh, affect molecules.
Well,
the absolutely affect so many different
aspects of your body and for anyone who
doubts that the placebo
effect is measurable,
I mean the placebo effect is
nothing more than your brain that
it's got the cure.
So it reacts as if it's got the cure
and then things get better. I mean,
measurable amounts.
Uh, yeah, I made is amazing. Like how many
studies have shown that placebo effect,
it all comes down to belief system and
believe in yourself and believing that
you have the power to
heal. I mean, you know,
I don't know whether you're religious
or not, but I mean, you know,
you hear about the miracles of Christ
and you hear that the miracles of other
profits and so forth. I mean,
you know, it's documented.
A lot of these things happen.
I don't,
I don't buy into anything that's old
when it comes to documentation of certain
acts because it's so difficult to find
out what the fuck actually happened.
I find religious texts to be fascinating
and enlightening and a lot of ways I
think you can learn a lot about
what they learned about wisdom,
what they learned about the correct
path to living a happy, healthy life.
But a lot of those principles, you
know, the golden rules, the of,
of Christianity, of Islam, of
a lot of different religions,
they essentially comes down to wisdom,
life lessons learned over
long periods of time,
but then translated into sort of some
sort of a weird mez metaphysical deity
connection that gets a little
sketchy. You know, like, you know,
Christ rising from the dead and
all this stuff. It's like, boy,
what really happened?
You're,
you're talking about thousands of years
of stories in over a thousand years
before anybody wrote anything
down. You know, stories are
the,
most of the things that were written down
were several centuries after the fact.
So yeah, I agree. But I, I have, uh,
[inaudible] the late 18 hundreds,
early 19 hundreds,
there was a movement in the United
States and through Europe called the new
thought, where people began to
realize that thoughts are things,
it's an energy form.
And that you,
when you think thanks and
especially when you say things,
you're actually putting energy into
action. It's the law of attraction.
So you're basically attracting what you're
putting out. I mean, that's been long.
I just did in physics. And that's,
that's basically, you know, what, what,
uh, Einstein was talking about. In what
way was he talking about that? Well,
for every action there's a reaction.
If you're putting out negative thinking,
negative statements,
you can only attract same.
It's virtually impossible for
any good to come from bad.
Well, it's funny how that sounds so
simplistic, but for anybody or simplistic,
but anybody who doubts that run
into people that go, oh fuck,
nothing good ever happens to
me. Those people, you're right,
nothing good ever happens to you.
That's, you know, you have that,
you have this mindset and then you run
into people that say, hey, you know,
we're gonna work through this. We're
going to figure it out, and it's,
this is only gonna make us better and
stronger. Let's keep pushing forward.
Those people seem to always prosper
and I don't know whether or not luck is
involved. I don't know whether or
not it's all just your attitude,
but I do know that the people
that have that great attitude,
I feel better when I'm
around them and it's,
it's empowers me and I feel like it
enables me to also spread that empowerment
on to other folks.
Well, as a whole energy, you know, it's
like, guys, oh, I can't afford this.
I can't afford that.
You're right. You can't.
It's like going into a fight and
you already thought you lose,
you're going to lose man.
No fighter goes into a fight believing
that he's going to lose the fight.
If he does go in, he's pretty
much going to get his ass kicked
by. That said, if you're
some guy who's not very good,
but you've got this crazy belief in
yourself and you fight John fucking Jones,
you're still gonna get your ass kicked.
And it only works up to a certain
point up to a certain point, they guys,
then there's other factors that
come into town. There's a lot of
the, the, the, the positive belief system
has to be grounded in reality. Yes. Right.
Yeah. Obviously if I, you know,
if somehow I could be convinced that I
could fly and I jump off this building,
I'm going to go splat.
Yeah. And the, the, the, you
know, people that are into like,
the secret will tell you,
you didn't really believe
well, May, who knows, man, you
know, I, I've my belief system,
does it go past a certain point?
But maybe that's my limiting factor.
But I do know when it comes to the body,
you have an amazing
capacity for self healing.
And I, I've actually
undergone it with my own body.
Well, the people that really,
truly believe that we are
in some way or another,
the vehicle of God that is there,
that's sort of what they point to.
That we manifest our reality with our
own mind and our own intent and with our
own actions and our own thoughts.
And that as we grow and as we evolved
and as we get stronger and stronger with
our consciousness and our
ability to understand this,
that we enact those powers more
freely and more consciously and, uh,
that, that our intent truly does
create they're very universe around us.
It sounds a little ridiculous,
but then when you start and think what,
how much of an effect human
beings have on the environment?
How much of an affect
human beings have on earth?
And when you stop and think about all
the bad things that go on in earth,
whether it's war or pollution or
what is that? It's like there's this,
there's a lack of attention and a lack
of intent on the important aspects of
harmonious relationships
with your environment,
whether it's with people or let's take
like just one small example of like how
my belief system works about this.
Uh,
there's this one thing called the
accumulation mindset. I call it, uh,
I work online with people on fat loss
programs and when you really look at their
lifestyle,
their into the z accumulation mode of
just buying an amassing all this stuff.
I've been in some people's homes where
the shelves are just littered with stuff
they never use or don't need. You know,
they, they just have so much stuff.
The attic is full of stuff,
the garage is full of stuff,
but they buying more and more,
adding, adding, adding, adding.
Their bodies reflect this
type of belief system.
And for sure they're adding more cells
under their body. Just indulge it,
you know?
And then they find themselves over eating,
eating more than their fair share of
the natural resources of the universe.
Taking more n a,
I mean,
it's just like this whole
belief system in accumulation.
Like I need to add, I need to add
is all subconscious. Of course,
no one goes into it.
Yeah. I have friends that are overweight
and when I watched them sometimes eat,
I almost see like a person who's
a consuming a drug, you know,
you see them like they know they shouldn't
have it, but they're like, fuck it.
Give it to me. Uh, a relief, you
know? And I don't know what it is,
whether it's a distraction
from their own mortality,
whether it was just some sort of a
weird hitch in the system of though the,
the way the mind interacts with the world.
Like it's just too much stress and too
many variables and they need something to
sort of inject them out of that. So they
focus entirely on an ice cream Sundae.
But Eh, knowing that they
shouldn't even have it, go fuck it.
We're going to have it anyway.
And so by doing that,
you sort of block off all your awareness
and just funnel that stuff down your
fucking pie hole until you're,
it's like an addiction to the pleasure
centers of the body. You know,
you get like that little drug,
lack of response in the brain for a
moment in time, you know, when do you,
when you eat this kind of stuff.
And so you get like that little chemical
reward that the brain puts out for
having like this big thing is sugar or
whatever. You know, you get that rush,
but then there's quickly replaced
with either disgust or south loathing,
but sets up another cycle because
now you get depressed again.
But you need that little brain reward
and man, it can be pretty tough.
And it really parallels with
gambling addiction, right? Yeah.
Well I mean same sort of thing. Very
common. I mean if you think about it,
you can kick cigarettes,
you can kick most drugs.
It's cigarettes are tough for most people.
One of the toughest things
you give up is that nicotine.
But any drug you can give up, you can
get off alcohol. All those things. Right,
but you don't need those things,
but you do need to eat. Food.
Addiction is very common and it's the
toughest one to give up because you can
never not eat.
That's a very good point. It's a
very good way of putting it. I don't,
I don't think I've ever heard
anybody put it that way.
It's such an important way to describe
it because you'll always get to know.
It's like if you were a heroin
addict and you go, okay,
I can't just shoot up until I pass out.
I'm just going to shoot a little bit.
Keep Pamper happy. Yeah. I mean
that's really similar. You need it.
You need food if you don't, and if you're
addicted to food and you need food.
Yeah. I've had friends who lost a lot of
weight and they look great and like, Oh,
you look great.
You lost all this weight.
Well, a year later, so he said,
well, think of it as a species.
Our survival depended on our belt.
The lay down in a rapidly I body fat.
We were programmed,
overeat,
and eat as much as possible because
food was not very prevalent right now in
this modern
society with food, you know,
so easily to get, I mean,
our genetics actually work
against us while it's probably
like why sex addiction,
this exists as well too,
like your,
it was hard for human beings to breed
and even harder for them to stay alive.
So it was imperative that we breed as
much as possible to spread the population
as far as possible.
And so that that pleasure reward system
that's in place to make sure that you
keep breeding and just throw is a hiccup
gets thrown into it when you inject it
into modern society where you don't
really have as many issues about breeding,
but he's still have this genetic
impulse to constantly need to,
to fuck and spread your seat.
Yeah. Yeah. Stuff. Your face breed.
But I don't get the gambling
one. The gambling one's a
weird one, right? Where the,
where the hell did that one come from?
That's still a brain reward and you get
that rush, that excitement. You know, why?
Why would I guess to take risks in the
rewards of what these guys needed to get
out and do a sport and replace it with
that. But instead they get it from the,
the rush of, you know, putting it all
in the line. But yeah. Well I mean,
think of like some of the
adrenaline sports like rock
climbing. So it was crazy.
Dudes like climate without
safety harnesses or Alex handled.
We had him on the podcast. We have
the craziest of all. One Kid, uh,
the, the one free climber just died
recently, but that's just one who died.
There was a guy who was
written in outside magazine.
They did a little tribute to this
guy. But hope is not Alex. I have no,
I would have heard of Alex Todd because
he's the craziest of all of them.
We had them on the podcast.
He's the most mellow kid ever.
But think about the base jumping.
There's two crazy dudes that jumped
off that tower and Dubai, you know,
that's sad. But that's the type of, you
know, adrenaline rush. But you know,
like guys like you and me, we
get that going on the mat. Yeah.
Yeah. That's, I think that is a big thing.
The pushing yourself and the reward of,
and that's the difference
between a martial art as well.
Then really in my opinion,
the difference in Jujitsu as opposed
to all the other martial arts.
Because I enjoyed kickboxing
and I enjoyed taekwondo.
I enjoyed, uh, competing. I
certainly got a lot out of it.
It's certainly shaped me as a man,
but I never felt good when
I knocked somebody out.
I always felt weird to the body. Wasn't
that bad. It didn't bother me that much.
But man, when I, when I would head
kick guys and watch them fold,
it was a terrible feeling. Pretty sick.
I've never enjoyed it. I never felt good.
And even worse when you get head
care. Yeah, way worse. I got lucky.
I got stopped only once in
my entire career and it was
a kickboxing bound and it
was more out of exhaustion than anything.
It was the third fight in, in the night.
I won my first one by Kao,
I wanted my second one.
It was a two, went to two a two
round. Both of them were too. It was,
cause you fought three times in the night.
So there were two round fights. So, uh,
first one on one by Saquon was just a,
a kick the guy's ass.
But then I had a long period of break
between the second find the third,
and I was just fucking exhausted and
I was kind of sick too. And then, uh,
I got hit with a left hook and the second
round and my, my legs just gave out.
But I was conscious it was nothing bad.
It was like,
and then that was the last fight I had
and I was in the middle of like doing
comedy and competing at the same
time. I was saying, you know what,
if I can get out of this with thinking
about all the shit that I did to people,
if I can get out of it with
just one left hook to the face,
because my instinct initially was,
I'm not going on a loss. Fuck that.
I'm coming back. I'm going to find that
guy, I'm gonna beat the fuck out of him.
And my initial instinct was to start
training like a fucking madman,
abandoned comedy,
but that was emotional.
Within a week or two I sort of realized
I have a different comment since that's
it. I realized I had a
different goal too that I,
I changed the way I train and I wasn't
training like I was when I was younger
and when I was completely
obsessed with competition.
Now I had all these
different requirements.
I was now no longer live with my parents
now I was feeding myself when I was
working and I was worried about my future.
I was like,
what am I going to do for a living?
Like what am I doing here? I'm teaching,
there's not much money in that. And
I go, what am I doing? I'm like,
be a kickboxer and get fucking brain
damage. So it was all these very,
so I was terrified that I was going to
run into me when I was 19 who was just a
psycho that just trained constantly and
lived at home and didn't have many bills.
And just every day I'd get up and run
hills and stairs and just all I was
thinking of is I got to do things that
other people aren't doing because that
way I'll win, you know, and
I wasn't doing that anymore.
So I kind of recognized
it was always like,
if I can get away with one loss like that,
like that kind of loss.
We're good because I didn't want anybody
kicking me the way I kicked people.
I just fucking, I've seen it happen
to friends to like good friend Mike,
my friend Larry, he when we were like,
um, he was a little bit older than me,
I think I was 18 and we went to this
tournament and he fought this Canadian
national champion that's Kinda named
Jersey long and he got hit with an ax kick
in the head and I'll never forget it.
I'll never forget watching this guy whip
his leg up like more than a split and
slam that heel down on my friend's
face and he just crumpled.
And I was like, Dad, it's just not
something I ever want to happen to me.
It's a brutal way to make a living.
And when you do it to somebody,
it doesn't feel good. When you choke
someone out in Jujitsu and they tap,
it doesn't feel bad at all, you
know? Yeah. You're not hurting him.
I'm never broken anybody's arm. I mean,
I've never been in, in class. I've never,
I mean, I've seen guys
get injured, you know,
accidentally knees blowout and stuff
like that, but it's always an accident.
It's never, you know, never an
intentional thing, at least on my behalf.
So I never felt bad about it. So I got
all that. The competition to thrill,
the energy, the excitement,
all the discharge,
the adrenaline without any of the bad
Karma feelings that you get from kicking
somebody, you know? Because
there's something about, you know,
that kind of competition
where you have to put almost,
you have to put your humanity
aside in order to, to compete in,
in a mixed martial arts or
in, so I tell people, like,
when people come to me
for advice about fighting,
while I'm thinking about fighting,
we'll stop right there.
Because if you're just thinking about
it, don't fucking do it. Okay? If you,
if you have to be completely obsessed
and if you're not completely obsessed,
you're going to fight someone who is
and you're going to get fucking killed.
Think about someone who's not completely
obsessed fighting Vandelay Silva in his
prime. Just imagine that. Okay, and then
do you want that to happen to you? No.
Then don't do it. But if you want to be
Vandelay Silva, if that's your destiny,
then do it. But it, unless
that's your destiny,
unless that is you and I don't
know what the fuck anybody,
I don't know what makes someone want
to be a folk singer. I don't get it.
I don't understand.
Someone has it in their head to get up
every morning and do macrame and that's
what they want to do.
That I would never discourage it,
but you must have that in your head.
If you want to be a fighter,
you have to only have that in your head.
If you have anything in your head,
any doubts. If you have any problem
with giving people concussions, get out.
Don't do it because
you're going to run it.
I don't believe in dabbling and
fighting. You can't not do it. Oh,
it's uh,
like you say,
the risk to benefit ratio of that type of
activity. It's just, it's just terrible.
So when you've had injuries and you
have done what you say is a prayer and
meditation and focusing,
what is the process?
Do you put yourself in a
certain particular state
when you're trying to heal
something? Like how do you go about
doing it? That's really famous.
A guy by the name of Neville Goddard who,
uh,
wrote about the power of visualization.
A lot of it has to do with visualization.
Visualizing yourself as whole as being,
well, uh, you know, there's like a,
like there's a, you know, we're all
born with this perfect DNA blueprint,
but then we get skewed somehow as we get
older or through injuries and set forth.
So I try to visualize
like being like that,
that perfect little kid that had full
mobility and ability to move and so forth.
And there's the step by step process.
You literally generate the feeling of
being that fighters did this all the time.
You know, they are are great
athletes, like, uh, you know, uh,
John Mcenroe or somebody, you
know, they, they, they're able,
they had this power to
visualize themselves in certain
situations and prevailing
or, or winning. And I mean
in, in all walks of life.
Well,
I certainly know use visuals,
whether they know it or not,
even if they're unconscious of it,
they're still using it.
Yeah. There's certain folks that just,
they have super confident and they,
I only see myself winning,
but there's other folks,
like I know frank shamrock talked about
that a lot that he used to go through.
He was a big proponent of visualization
and when he was in his prime and he
would go through all these different
scenarios and see himself winning,
go through all these different
scenarios. A lot of people, you know,
don't give frank shamrock enough credit.
Like back in the day,
frank was the well balanced
mixed martial artists. I mean,
he was a fantastic fighter. I never in
this era match you had was Enovia man.
Oh yeah. Woo Man. Yeah, that
was a quick one. You know,
that was a crazy slam and he broke
his collarbone. Fucked him up.
I just, that devastating Aa
pickup throw he did. Right.
Frank was an animal. Yeah.
Well how about, you know,
when he beat Kevin Jackson with that
arm bar in Japan to win the title? No.
You know, at the time he beat
uh, uh, who was the, the bad boy,
Tito Ortiz. She had already days cardio
dance. He was way smaller than, you know,
he used Jujitsu. He basically was
repeatedly taken down by Tito Ortiz.
Use the guard as good as any Jujitsu guy
I've ever seen. We get back to his feet.
Tito got tired of taking him down and he
couldn't do anything with them cause he
used beautiful guard work. I was
shocked at how good is she just, it was,
well that was an important fight for MMA
as well because that was an important
fight where people understood the benefit
and then the need for cardio because
frank had tremendous cardio.
Frank was also training with
Maury Smith who was a huge,
huge cardio fiend. Maurice would
swim. He was an animal, he would just,
he would put those weird paddle things
on your hands and just do lap after lap.
And that's how he wound up beating
Mark Coleman. Same strategy.
Mark Coleman took them
down over and over again.
Maurice defended while he was on the
bottom and then eventually got up and he
was fresh still cause it's cardio was
so good. Mark was exhausted than more,
he started kicking the shit
out of his legs. You know,
Maurice implied that strategy applied
rather that strategy many times.
And you know, I think frank learned a
lot from Maurice in that respect too.
But that fight was a big,
when you think about how,
how young MMA was back then, I
mean, when did he fight Tito?
Was at 96 or something like that,
somewhere around there.
It was really in the early days.
Really in the early day.
So three or four years into the UFC?
No,
it must've been after 96 because I
was there for Tito's first fight,
which was 97. I was there, um, uh, west.
All Britain, I think he fought. He
came in as an alternate. I was there,
I interviewed him, I think he
was 19 at the time. And uh,
and he won in that fight and then he
got submitted by Guy Metzker Guy Metzger
caught him in a guillotine. And then, um,
he went on to, uh, when he fought
frank shamrock after that fight,
he became a cardio machine cardio machine.
And he taught a lot of guys that,
like when I talked to Kendall
Grove after Kendall did,
Tom and the ultimate fighter came
out like a much improved fighter.
And one of the thing that he said to me,
Kendall said,
I learned from Tito that cardio is
everything. You know, these guys learned.
We saw that the growth, you know,
we saw these guys learning like,
well I sure as often as the sport. Well,
you know, I, I don't know what that,
I ever told you this, but I was one
of the original investors in the UFC.
My actual DC Maxwell. Yes. Or,
and Gracie puts that first UFC together
to shoestring budget in Denver. Wow.
And he was going around to all his friends
and we were all kicking in a little
bit of money and you know, I had a
little extra money saved up. I, I
actually had a retirement account as
a school teacher and I had some money
sitting in the bank. I said, sure.
And so he went to like a whole
bunch of different people,
put it together on a shoestring
and thus was born that first UFC.
And he wanted to use it as a showcase
to show the superiority of Jujitsu or
basically what happens here if you
don't know how to find in the ground.
And then he picked the most unlikely guy
cause he could add Hickson who was just
a stunned, but he was afraid that
people say, wow, that's excellent.
Look at the physique,
looking to athleticism.
He wanted to pick a voice who was
a really nice kid, pretty thin,
wasn't particularly strong.
He was perfect God to showcase
the technique of Jujitsu.
There's also that what I'd heard was
that he couldn't control Hickson and they
didn't like that. Hixon [inaudible]
wild man. Yeah, he's his own man.
He wasn't going to tell them what to do.
And voice was a very young naive kid.
And you know, he's pretty, yeah,
he pretty much listened to what Horry
and told him to do and it just makes it
amazing what he did in this first UFC is,
but the big difference was the no gloves.
Every one was breaking their
hands. Yup. And I'm telling you,
you take the gloves off,
you would still see wrestlers and
Jujitsu guys went almost every fight.
But for the average audience,
I think it would be boring.
I want to see the spectacular
knockouts and you know,
you're not going to get this particular
knockouts with the bare fist like you
would with those gloves would
with knees. And uh, you know,
for sure ties advanced Ligo.
We had Orlando Veit who's like one of the,
the best early guys.
Striker answers are really high level
kickboxer who was in the early UFC.
But um, I, I agree with you. You wouldn't
see nearly as much punching to the face.
You, your hands break. All guys would
have to do is just duck their head down.
You hit their forehead, you know, if you
want to punch me in the forehead, shit,
go ahead. Go for it. Nice to be hedging
strategy and self defense. You know,
he just like Headbutt the hand
and it's pretty much done then.
But the other thing too was with the no
time limit thing that they had back in
those days,
you know where you'd just go and get that.
That was very terrifying for a
lot of guys. Oh my God. You know,
I feel my gas going and
people were just literally,
you can't recover panic now there there's
no sitting on a stool ice bag on the
back of your neck, have a sip of
water. Someone who's picky feet up,
relaxing your legs and none of that,
you know,
you just gotta fucking mark her on top
of you dropping elbows in your face.
They hair pool and they had the
punching to the testicle. I mean,
it really was.
And that it really is amazing what hoists
accomplished when you think about that.
We don't fuck three or four
times in one night. Gee,
it's impossible under
estimate to underemphasize it.
I mean, or or over emphasize it. What
an amazing thing he accomplished.
It really truly is.
And that fight he had with Matt Hughes,
that wasn't the same
hoists, Gracie, you know,
I mean that was pretty much him past
his prime and addition to wearing gloves
and not wearing the key.
I mean it
was just everything.
I know he must have felt incredibly
uncomfortable in that particular fight,
you know?
Well he was also fighting a
monster and we, Matt uses in March,
he was fighting a monster at 175 pounds.
He didn't want to lose the weight.
So he let Matt Hughes
be even fucking bigger.
And Matt Hughes is a God damn gorilla
and has really good Jujitsu. Mad.
He was just him.
I mean,
that was the thing about what Matt
Hughes did to him in that fight.
He took voices fucking back
flatten amount was pounding on him.
The fight ended with Matt Hughes having
both of his hooks in on top of him
because he jujitsu when hoisted it guys
thousands of times and he was Oco real.
Ah,
Matthew is back then was a gorilla.
He had these neck muscles,
like you look at the back of his neck,
it's like he's got to kill bosses,
don't even kill bosses.
Like what of those look
really fat Salamis,
you know that go from the base of the
spine outward towards the traps and he's
such a fucking animal with good technique.
Good technique, great techniques.
By the way, some of the guys,
sometimes guys as far apart as I saw it,
like a video clip,
it was like a WHO's who of like high
level Jujitsu guys and he was more than
handling this outfit in the, in
digital row. Yeah. And He'd already,
Ben threw scraps with guys like Bj Penn.
He had trained on a regular basis with a,
you know, really, really high level guys,
both at Pat and Mila touches
and other gym, you know,
I mean he had guys to train
with them on a, he's just,
he was constantly around
guys that were like really,
really high level and he's
being pushed in title fights,
who's being pushed and like, and hoist
had been out of the game for quite awhile,
but boy did that sell. You know,
everybody wanted to see it.
Everyone wanted to say it. But to
me it was, uh, it was kind of sad.
It was, well, you know, hoist was
really a hero to me. You know,
I just hated to see if,
because people sort of undermine at him.
I C G g a UFC is,
uh,
becomes so much more
sophisticated and look,
there's old ones you can never
hang with these guys. That's,
that's not true at all,
man. It was just, well,
it had been really interesting to
see hoists in his prime was picky.
The versus Matt Hughes. That would have
been, yeah, it would've been interesting.
But it's also,
you've got to realize that one of the
reasons why Matt Hughes was so good is it
Matt Hughes had benefited from all the
lessons that we had all learned voice
from boys entering into UFC one UFC
two. And then of course, Jeremy Horn,
who was training all the time with Matt,
who was a huge student of the game.
And one of the most technical guys,
like Jeremy Horn is a perfect example
because Jeremy is a really smart guy.
No Ego who has a body that is just,
there's nothing super powerful
or unusually athletic,
nothing extra long about him.
Just excellent technique and
intelligence and you know,
he worked a lot with Matt.
Matt got to, you know,
learn a lot of techniques from him.
The BJ Penn fights of course,
Bj Penn Moon Dealz champion, one of
the best Jujitsu guys ever. Guys ever.
And so he mad at,
you know,
the, the game past toys up, you know,
that things had changed and
his body wasn't the same. Yeah.
It became a real bonafide sport.
I think those early, early UFC is,
we're pretty much like real fights
and like street fights, you know,
you know how they used to try out for,
this is crazy man.
I was actually caught into the
ballroom by horror end one time.
They had guys trying out for the UFC in
the ballroom and they'd get hilly and
Gracie and they would have a
couple of other, the Gracie family,
they would put on a knee pads and
fight in these hotel ballrooms.
Whoa. Yeah. To see if it was bare
knuckle they would just go, man, wow.
It was a whole mine to find
out if a guy's any good.
There's all Gracie in action tapes to find
out if the guy was any good. And yeah,
they know the early uh, ultimate
fighters, you know, they have,
they would have a guy,
they had guys fighting the early ultimate
fighters that had no fights. Zero.
And they would get those guys and
they would have them hit the pads.
They'd have a guy hold a
tie pads farm. Okay, got it.
Got some striking techniques and they'd
have them roll a little bit. Okay.
It looks like he could roll,
get in there and then they put him
on the ultimate fighter. I mean,
there's quite a few guys that they had
to did that of really ultimately of
course as the show evolved,
like all things,
but now you're getting
guys like Uriah Hall,
they come into the ultimate
fighter already a killer, you know,
and just lighting guys on fire when
they get in there. The fascinating,
fascinating to be a part of the
evolution of all of that really.
And you know that the training has really
evolved to that was going to ask you
about that. Let's talk for example about
you mentioned muscularity and straight.
How much would you need to
be by suppression? Right?
Well obviously it's a weight class
sport and you wouldn't be as light as
possible and as strong
as absolutely possible.
So absolute strength is pretty important.
There's a fixed ratio between absolute
strength and muscular endurance.
Strength is a fixed ratio,
so if you increase your ability to
lift a really heavy weight one time,
your endurance with a lighter
weight is going to also improve.
Let's say you managed to build from 80
pounds to 100 pounds and a bicep curl,
and prior to that you could take 50 pounds
and maybe you could do 10 when you go
from your 82 year a hundred pounds curl,
your ability to,
if you went back to that same 50
pants that you could do 10 with,
you probably do about 13 or 14 reps now.
So there's a fixed ratio between
strength and muscular endurance.
That's interesting. So if you do
chin ups, like say if you can do,
I can do 20 chin-ups.
That's pretty remarkable by it.
That's always been like an amazing
standard. Well you kind of stuff,
I always tell people, listen,
I learned a lot from you. Um,
but if I did it with a weight
belt, you know, like a um,
like a dip belt and a like a barbell
or a dumbbell plate underneath it,
that would probably
make my chin ups better.
And what I probably get
to my ultimate goal,
I want to be able to do 30 straight
arm chin ups, like all the way down.
Which one's a chin up?
Like this way it's my palms facing.
That's the way I always do it.
Cause I feel like that's
more applicable to Jujitsu.
And you don't really choke anybody like
this. Yeah. You're doing a Geechee. Yeah,
but I don't really like it chokes
when I used the geek, I don't,
I don't use the gay. Like I, I use
a g for, I rolled with the gate.
I have a black belt in the game,
but my game is completely
defensive with Biggie.
Like I um, I do the same
techniques over hooks, under hooks.
I do, you know, same type of Jujitsu.
I go for chokes and arm bars.
I don't try to collar
choke people very rarely.
I do the clock choke every now and in
the same one that believes you caught a
hoist with yes. Put them to
sleep with. That's a beautiful,
beautiful chat cause I
love the spin underneath.
It's such a Ninja move but if you
think about it like, you know,
they'll say wise it's not,
the grips is the hips and really top
practitioners in both gay and no gate.
A lot of times the game is at virtually
the same solid for example or Shawn Gee
there the game is pretty much
the same whiskey without gay.
They don't get overly dependent on grip.
There's so many guys though that do
and we used to see that in the UFC.
These guys who are one Dealz champion,
high level gay guys,
but they relied so much on spider guard,
so much on grabbing the sleeves.
So much on the fucking shit is
gone when everybody's sweaty.
When you got a sweaty guy in
his underwear on top of you,
drop an elbow on your face and
he happens to be a wrestler.
So he knows how to grapple
and how to use this way,
keep you thin down reaching for shit
that's not there. Instead of, you know,
under hooks and you know,
overlooks and controlling your body.
Use the body and not the, the, the jacket.
Well that's what Eddie Bravo always
emphasized that like so many of the
techniques of Jujitsu that these people
relied on and trained on a regular basis,
they just weren't applicable.
You know, who's like,
do you see judo guys training
Greco Roman to get better at June?
You see the uh,
the you Sushi Miyaki the three time
world Greco Roman wrestling champion,
his judo game and his Greco Roman
wrestling game were firstly identical.
So he did both the same way as a sort of
the same. There's a huge under hook man.
Uh, you did not want to get an a in
his life. Once he had that under hook.
It wasn't a matter if you're going
to be thrown just a matter of when.
And it was terrifying experience.
I was on the receiving end
and the guy was like brutal.
Well when you see the guys that are like
really good at judo and they can apply
it to MMA, it's so beautiful.
Like Hector Lombard.
Did you see Hector Lombard
versus Jake shields?
That was quite a magnificent
match the way through him though.
And who was that cringe
Weirdo guy and pride.
That was just toss and dude's the uh,
Korean judo guy.
Where's the guy that won
the gold medal from Korea?
That was just a magnificent throws.
It was in one of the Japanese Yoshida.
You're talking about your shopping list,
but he was a Japanese can I know,
give a shit.
It was another Japanese show.
I just remember watching it
and just watching this Jira
guy really cause Akiyama
was it?
Akiyama was a judo guy.
He was pretty high with Korean
gold medalists in the Olympics.
Think almost like half Korean and half,
half Japanese. I'm not sure. I never sent
he really church.
He took the judo and really turned it
into quite a fighting art without the gay.
It's really fun to watch.
I wish I could remember the show,
but I was hoping you'd remember.
Yeah. Um, well if you said his name,
I've paid you for this stuff, man. I
don't have any other sports in my head.
I have a Jujitsu, uh, kickboxing and MMA.
That's all I have in my head.
But you asked me some football questions.
I'll stare at you bet. Let's go back to
strength training. Yes, please. Well,
there there's a point of
diminishing returns where
getting stronger is not going
to improve your performance anymore.
In order to get stronger
past a certain point,
you have to almost become
a strength specialist.
And this is where a lot
of guys get mixed up.
They start training like a power lifter
or Olympic weightlifter. Big Mistake.
Okay?
The majority of retailers should be
going into improving your skillset.
That's the single most important thing
when it comes to endurance. Now, you know,
we talk about cardio and gas,
right?
The absolute best way to get your cardio
and gas at a high level is to wrestle
or to do MMA. The problem is a
lot of these guys are so good,
they have no one to push their gas.
For example,
I trained Shawn g barrow
the the year he won, uh,
Abu Dhabi in Barcelona and he
took second in the open division.
He hurt his shoulder in the finals,
but he won his division.
He was so good that there was no one
in the room to push it. Man. I mean,
this guy's like so good. So
elite to, I had, I had to,
I had to, to, to pre exhaustion
before he would train.
I put in through growing circuits
and such to rarely, you know,
bring his cardio up and get him really
tired before he would roll before he
wrote. So, so that even an average
dude can give him a hard time.
So now I have no juice left.
I got to use short technique in
order to be ever to do what I do.
That's fascinating. So that when
he could roll when he was fresh,
it was probably a real treat. Oh yeah.
I mean it was this play. In fact, he,
I was actually in Oslo,
Norway at the time when he won,
he texted me and it was one of the nicest
things anyone ever has. And he says,
coach, I didn't even get tired
at all. And it was like, yes,
the strategy really, really worked well.
You come up with some brutal workouts,
man, I still have those suspension
things that you gave me those, uh,
but normally normally you wouldn't
need those type of brutal workouts.
If you're getting high level
competition on the mat,
it almost be would be too much.
It pushed you towards over training.
That's interesting. So like a guy
like fate or like, or fuel door,
however you want to say it
and if you want to be correct,
he and his at his best stopped all the
strength and conditioning training and
all he would do is fight
specific training. Pretty
much sports specific training,
which was always the Russian model.
Uh,
I do believe that you didn't need
to keep her absolute strength up.
You do need to lift weights a couple
of times a week just to keep, you know,
fairly heavyweight low wrap,
but don't tax yourself.
Use it sort of as a tonic and then really
push yourself in the gym to get your
hard rolls onto, develop your
sports specific conditioning
because let's face it,
all the rope skipping,
running kettlebell swings stairs isn't
the same as getting on the map. Right?
It's slightly different energy systems.
You're using muscles,
different firing patterns and yes.
Okay.
If you don't have someone
to push you in the gym, yes,
this stuff is one way to do it,
but it's not the ideal way because
most MMA guys, let's face it, it's,
it's like a full time profession
man. You're doing, you're wrestling,
you're doing your kickboxing or boxing
or whatever you're doing, your Jujitsu.
My God,
there's three disciplines.
It's like the triad being in a
triathlon or triathlete, you know,
you'll have to equally divide up.
I found too that being when you
get injured and then come back,
it's always horrifying. Like the,
the Co, like if I, it would, uh,
like tore my knee,
my knee meniscus,
I had it scoped and then I was out for
a couple months and then come back and
he's just like, oh, death, you know,
like a couple of minutes
and you're just a dead man.
And one of the ways that I mitigated
that was kettlebell training.
Well yeah,
I mean when you're hurt or
you have injuries or you
don't have people to push to
the gym,
there are ways that you can very closely
simulates the energy systems that you
would use an actual grappling.
It's never as good as actual grappling
or kickboxing or whatever it really,
because you're forced to
react to the other person,
which you're not when you're training.
So even when you're pushing hard,
you're still pushing hard at your pace.
You're not reacting to someone else's
pace and relaxing and breathing while you
were reacting to someone else's
cause that's the big one. Yeah.
And the other thing,
like I mentioned that wasn't real
big fan of like Olympic lifting.
Olympic lifts are very technical,
very amazing athletic feat to basically
you're basically throwing a barbell over
your head and jumping
underneath it simultaneously.
That's what Olympic lifting is.
Very specific movement pattern has
nothing to do with martial arts. You know,
when's the last time you saw anyone lift
something over their head in martial
arts? Very rarely, you know,
as this tank Abbott trying to throw
somebody out of the cage and the skills
required to Olympic
lifter really high level.
I mean these guys are amazing
athletes in their own right,
but becoming an Olympic lifters not
going to make you better on the mat.
It just isn't.
The Morse uh,
skill level at an exercise
takes the higher the skill,
the less care of her
value to anything else.
That's why he went and keep your
workouts fairly general, fairly simple,
like your chin ups,
fantastic care of her to any
martial art because it's fair.
General is no skill.
You pull yourself up or you dump,
you really develop a tremendous
amount of strength and in your case,
strength endurance.
So dead lifts, squats, cleans.
Yeah. So why don't I got from
you is alternating cleans.
I love that one with kettlebells.
Kettlebells. That's one of my favorites.
Barbell clean and fan only because of
the way it can affect your back in a
really negative way. You mess up a
barbell clean, it can really screw your,
your uh,
your lower back.
Let's face it while we do on the mat is
dangerous enough in the ring and the Mat.
It's pretty dangerous. Yeah. Alrighty.
So I don't need to make my workouts,
you know, I don't need to include
traumatic type exercises like that. Right.
I only use barbells or uh, yeah, barbells.
I only use it for a bench press and
um, I try not to that too much. Um,
but I will, if I don't have someone
there with me to help me spot,
cause it's hard to do
individual kettle bells with a,
with bench press or for dead lifts
for deadlift and bench press it.
Yeah.
That's what a barbells for cannibis or
for swings pretty much get ups, you know,
bodyweight training of course. Any
kind of pull up or a Chin up, uh,
obviously depths and push ups and
things are fantastic, you know,
right tool for the right thing there.
You know,
some people get really hung up and
kettlebells own way, but hey look,
he's just one tool in the box,
man. They're good. But you know,
there's plenty of other
but it doesn't simulate chin-ups right
now. A lot of things that catalog,
there's no uh, uh, vertical pulling
and uh, and kids about training.
So ideally you would do your general
strength training and then you get on the
mat and you get your conditionings need
met in the mat and the ring. So you would
say that if someone was like a high
level Jujitsu guy and you were looking to
just maintain strength or get stronger,
you almost wouldn't do
conditioning with weights.
You would almost do like heavyweights,
low res strength work,
low reps like you would take like maybe
like two 70 pound kettle bells and do
like alternate cleans. You
know, do some reps with
heavy swam turkeys get
apps and some Chins,
it'd be a 90 pound kettle bell with two
hands for swings. Exactly. Real heavy
low rep work, you know, and not worry
so much about developing strength,
endurance or cardio with the weights.
So you're just trying to get strong
with trying to get strong as you can for
your weight guys.
Now if you need to hypertrophy,
you need to change the reps a little bit.
If you need to armor up,
let's say I haven't worked in a guy that
might be planning NFL football and he
needs to put on some muscle, it's going
to be a slightly different protocol.
But we're,
you know,
we're specifically talking to like MMA
and a weight class sports like Jujitsu
and siblings and I purchase
hypertrophied that's,
I've always seen that
increase in muscular size.
There are some people that need
that and the way to get that,
it's just heavy low reps, right? Oh well,
no more moderate reps, moderate reps.
And the most important factor there is
what they call tall time under load.
You need to have your muscles under
certain, uh, tension for a specific time.
That seems to be the most,
in fact, an important factor
to increase muscle. Right.
What do you, do you believe in
slow lifting? Do you know that, uh,
that style of lifting,
especially for people that had been
injured like yourself and myself? Uh,
it can be a very good training tool.
I do a lot of slow rep work with myself
because I have had some trauma to my
shoulders and my neck and my back
over the years. You know, you don't,
you don't do 43 years of sports without
paying the price. Yeah. Last
time we worked out together,
you were having some real shoulder
problems. Did that get better? I did not.
It hasn't gotten worse. Wow. This is still
fucks with you. That's a, yeah. Well, I,
I developed some osteoarthritis in the
shoulder mostly from just doing silly
stuff, you know? Can you just snatches,
look into this Regena keen stuff, man,
it's fantastic for that. Yeah. You really
should. It's, it's fantastic for that. Um,
you're not a fan of, of a crossfit.
Not at all. Uh, for one thing,
there's not one elite athlete anywhere
in the world that actually uses crossfit
is the model. The second thing, the
second problem I have with crossfit,
Greg Glassman, the guy that
invented it, it's, it's, it's,
it's this secret that he's very
fat or an obese cripple basically,
who doesn't even train,
what kind of system is it
when the inventor of the
system is not a good example
of what he's putting out there? It's
crazy, right? I don't know who the guy is.
Okay, well, can we see them pull
him up? Jamie? He, he, you know,
the, uh, and of course then
the other thing is that's him.
Get the fuck out of here. No Way. Would
you, now when you listened to him over,
do you listen to me? I listen
to you anyway, but I mean,
okay, listen, you don't need to look like
a men's health fitness bottle to be an,
you know, looking at feed or not. I mean,
he looked like someone's dad, that
someone went into a bar and said, hey,
do you want a fight? And you know,
pulling them off the bar stool. And He,
I mean for sure if the best physique was
what determined who was going to win.
Bodybuilders would win every fight,
but that just doesn't happen.
But for sure you want to be an example.
You certainly don't want to be like
overweight and see if you can find some
other pictures of him. I mean, man caught
him on a bad day. Maybe he was bloated,
eat some,
eat some pastries on yourself.
That's what the guy looks like.
That's fucking crazy ass. Why?
Why? It has to tell you
some odd. That's really him.
There was a major university
study on crossfit. Right,
and for sure it improve
people's fitness levels.
They got improved vo two Max,
which is the measure of your ability
to process oxygen. They got stronger,
they lost body fat,
but when the study was looked at closely,
20% of the people involved with the
crossfit dropped out due to injury.
That means like if I'm a gym owner,
one out of every five of my clients is
getting hurt and I'm losing the client.
That's insane, man. Wow.
One out of every five because proper
training for athletics is supposed to
prevent injuries,
not cause injuries.
If you're hurting yourself in the gym
with your supplementary training, do you?
You got to go to a new model, man. Well,
who was that major crossfit guy
that just got paralyzed? Jamie,
pull that up if you can.
There's a guy who was in the crossfit,
he was like the crossfit games and he was,
you know,
a major star of crossfit and I don't
know what exercises he was doing,
but he dropped the bar on himself or
something and broke his back. Airlines,
our stories all the time. Joe
[inaudible], who's a buddy of mine,
he jumped like someone shot him.
Crossfit athletes was left paralyzed
after having a spine severed by a drop
barbell. Oh my God. So there once again,
risk to benefit ratio of the exercises.
And so many of these guys, they're,
they're competing and extras that how the
hell do you compete an exercise? Well,
I had a conversation with a guy who
was on, is that him right there?
We dropped it on them.
Oh my God.
Oh my God. It's falling
on its neck. Take it off.
Oh my God. Pretty screwed up man.
Oh my God. It just fell on his,
oh fuck. But think about this
for a minute. I said don't,
don't play the video. If I was
to say to you right now, hey,
let's do some push ups, we would use
good form and good technique, right?
We'd really be working for,
the true purpose of exercise is to give
a stimulus to our muscles so we get
stronger, right? Body adapts,
right? But if I said, hey man,
I bet you 20 bucks right now,
I can do more push ups than you.
You think we'd be doing good
reps after awhile for me.
Get rid of the window cause we
want to compete with each other.
That's the insanity of competing and
exercise and that's what crossfit does.
So exercise really should
only be to benefit sport.
Like your initial impulse to get
into exercise in the first place.
I had a guy you to make you a better
athlete to increase your performance.
The crossfit people need to get the fuck
out of there and start getting out in
the mat and do some real competition
because let's face it, everything,
every kind of sport is a sublimation
of man's desire to wage war.
Why not really do war and Dumont? Dumont
in combat. That's what I'm talking about.
Steve Maxwell,
Eh,
I had a kid on fear factor
once there was a crossfit, uh,
animal kid was in serious shape.
His girlfriend was a crossfit or two.
They were both like fucking really
fit. And I was like, dude, what do you,
what do you get out of it? And he's
like, you know, I just love competition.
I just love pushing myself. And I'm
like, okay, have you ever done Jujitsu?
You know, I tried to get them
to do it. I'm like, you would,
you're a fucking animal.
You're stud. I mean,
do you know what an advantage would
be to be this fit? Like you just go,
you could go on the mats like you, like
you would right away. He will, your,
your conditioning is so high.
Your vo two Max is so high.
You would just have to learn
the techniques and you'd
be able to already just
outwork people.
But you know,
the shocking thing though is a
lot of times the work is very,
very specific to the particular
sport you'd take. For example,
well I'll usually answer Armstrong.
You know the greatest endurance athlete,
right? Is what he was coined. I mean,
let's take all the drug stuff out.
They all used drugs. Okay. So yeah,
but he was the greatest psychos ever.
Amazing endurance. Right? His
first few 10 k runs, he suck, man.
He sucked because he didn't have this
specific movement patterns of running
right now he got better, you know,
he had that type of energy system.
But each sport is different. Right? You
take it a, you know, an average swimmer,
he's even a really high level swimmer.
He's going to be exhausted
in minutes on the mat. Yeah. But you
know, you take me and put me on a bike, I,
you know,
I'm not going to have any interference on,
on a mountain bike or a road
bike or whatever. You only,
you only develop endurance and a
very specific way. So you know,
the cross fit guys, believe me,
they would have to pay their dues.
It would take them a long time to adapt
to Jiu Jitsu or wrestling because I can,
I can remember being off the mat for a
long period of time and doing all these
heinous workouts with kettlebells
and bodyweight and all this.
Go on the Mat and Oh my God,
I would suck air so bad.
My gas would be horrible. I'm
thinking, what the hell man,
you know I'm in shape.
What the fuck? Yeah.
I was in shape to swing kettlebells and
to do burpees and it's not the same man.
Okay. It'd be better than if I hadn't done
those things at all. But let's face it,
there's no substitute for
doing the actual activity.
Especially if you're in there and you
have to roll with some savage who's in the
gym five days a week, training,
90 minutes a day, you know,
doing yoga in the morning, you know,
just to clear enough for Jujitsu
and part and part of the skill of she did.
So of course is conserving your energy
while you make the other guy put all his
energy out.
So you got that factor going in there too.
I found myself shocked at how bad a
shape I was in when I was in good Jujitsu
shape and I started kickboxing again.
After a few years off,
I had done no striking at all.
I mean like occasionally I go out to
the garage and hit the bag a little bit,
but like just abandoned it because I was
really trying to get my black belt and
then I started kickboxing when I
was in really good Jujitsu shape.
I could roll hard for a long period of
time and I fucking hit the pads for a
minute and I'd be exhausted.
It's amazing how sports specific endurance
body is specific adaptation
to imposed demand.
You can't get good at something
else by doing a particular activity.
You get good at that activity and the
body is amazingly specific when it comes
to that type of thing.
This is something I,
it took me awhile to kind of figure out,
so all of this crazy silly bugger of
waiving these battling ropes and so called
Nma circuits, you know, it's
just, you know, MMA, you know,
man Gai.
But don't you think that that's
important though to build a base?
Like that's one of the things that Diego
Sanchez told me that he does when he
trains.
He said he would take,
like say if he had a fight coming up in
like four months and he would take the
first six weeks and just concentrate
entirely on strength and conditioning,
just get himself very,
very, very fit and strong.
You want to have the base,
you know,
having an aerobic base for anaerobic
sports is, you know, been proven.
Having that type of, I remember even
in a wrestling season, you know, we,
we would do some, some uh, distance
runs, you know, couple miles, uh,
doing general strength training
just to, you know, build our,
our general strength up
to a pretty high level.
And then as the season progressed,
we get more and more specific with our,
with our drills and our training.
And you know,
the shark bait drills and have
you ever played that dro? Uh,
and Jujitsu first points,
everyone lines up against the wall.
You have your best three to
five guys out in the metal,
first guy to get the two points
stays. Yeah Man, I'm telling you,
even not at high level,
Blackbaud is going to get taken down
by a blue button at some point or get
scored on cause he gets that time.
But I mean that's the type of strength
endurance I'm talking about for, for,
for grappling.
I mean there's a brutal drills man.
Yeah. John's rock used to do one with,
with sweeps where he would uh, you,
you'd be on the bottom and fresh guys
would be on top. It's just brutal.
And as long as you could sweep the guy,
you stayed in there, but if he swept you,
you got off set for endurance.
No amount of, like I say,
supplementary training,
they can beat that. No way man. Just like
you found with the grappling, you know,
high level grappling conditioning, you
lost a lot of the endurance in the ring.
Now imagine MMA fighter that has to have
high level endurance and take downs,
high level endurance it kicking and
punching Hailo Dorrance of Jujitsu and the
ground.
He doesn't have time to be the burning
his body up with all this other nonsense.
He's going to be absolutely,
utterly overtrained in no
time at all on burnout.
And of course a lot of
these kids do get burnout.
Overtraining is really a pretty high and,
and,
and combat sports.
Yeah. How do they figure
out how they're overtrained?
Is it monitoring resting heart rate,
your morning resting heart rate morning?
Um, you take it first thing in bed when
you first wake up and you take it for let
seven days to get an out and that we're
assuming you're not already overtraining.
Right, right, right. Yeah. If
you suspect your overtrained,
you might want to take a couple of days
off and then start this process of seven
days in a row, taking your monitoring
your pulse, uh, on, uh, uh,
your iPhone.
There's an APP that you can actually hold
your finger on the camera lens and do
it.
It's pretty handy.
Instant heart, right? You hold
your finger on the camera lens,
there's an app on your, how does a camera
lens figure out what your fight is?
I don't know what the tech number,
galaxy s five,
the new Galaxy Samsung.
And one of the things I like about it
that I was thinking about picking it up is
it has a,
uh,
a heart rate monitor built into the
actual phone itself because they have some
sort of fit app.
It has something to do with the heat
coming up your finger is what I was toe
each pulse. It's a little bit of heat.
Yeah. Yeah. You see? Can you do it?
Do it right now. You have it on hand?
No, I uh, I'm embarrassed to say this,
but I was running here. Yeah. Uh,
I actually had gone downtown
and I lost my iPhone as,
as jogging to the show.
Like it fell out of your pocket.
I freaking fuck you can invest
in a fanny pack. Steve Maxwell.
I saw almost everyone. Okay,
man. I'm going to wear a
Joe Rogan. Vandy. Please do.
I would, it'd be honored.
Dammit. Leather roots iPhone.
So it's a vein out there
on Santa Monica Boulevard,
somewhere on that little trail.
And I was due for an iPhone five anyways.
Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah. Do you know if they
have that? Find your phone app? Yeah,
we were going to get
us if we could find it,
but some bum probably has it right now.
Some stinky bomb.
It was a lot of those in Santa
Monica, right? Oh Man. It's shocking.
How many bumps are on Santa Monica. Hey
Ben, look, if you gotta be homeless,
why not here man? It's a pretty
nice place to be homeless. Yeah,
it's definitely a good spot.
Or beats a Toronto or Chicago.
Fuck yeah. Siberia. Yeah. Yeah.
There's a brutal spots to be homeless.
So you hold your finger on the Lens.
You're doing it, Jamie. Is it working?
Yeah. And you can also monitor your
carotid artery. Your fucking heart rate.
62 beats per minute. That shit's
broken. Or your, let me see it.
You are you are you? I read seven miles
yesterday. Did you really fucking animal.
Look at you savage, dude. My
normal resting heart rate is 59.
Now remember I'm Kinda rushing rate is
when you first wake up in the morning
before you even get out of bed.
How do I start at?
Jamie was probably button on the bottom.
It might restart. There you go. Okay.
Let's see. And you put it over
the camera. Okay, here we go.
And then you just had amazing, yeah,
they technologies pretty crazy.
I'm going to try to, I'm not a tech
guy, but what's it called Jamie?
It's a bunch of incident heart right out.
And then it would record your
message and it'll keep, uh,
you will be able to,
well that's pretty fucking the record.
So once you know what the average
is, right, take for seven, divide,
that's, oh, it has options. Just
woke up before bed, exercising.
That's incredible that he
can figure it out from you.
Holding your finger over a camera.
What a world we live in. Well,
I don't want old world and amazing.
And you're talking to a guy that went
and used a cell phone or a laptop,
like for years.
When I first met you,
you had one of those blackberries
with the push button with the ski.
We would click, click, click. I
had one of those pieces of shit.
You remember that and you were like, this
is amazing. I can do everything on this.
You were so fired up about it.
So resting heart rate and then if your
morning resting pulse rate when you first
wake up is more than six or more beats,
you should not train that day.
That means if you have an elevated
heart rate, your stress Dude,
you have not recovered from
the previous day. Stress.
Elevated heart rate is
the first sign of stress.
So it's all that nonsense about pushing
yourself. You don't want to get up,
you got to get up anyway, push
through it. You feel like Shit, oh,
I push through it.
There's days where I just didn't
want to train but I forced myself to.
You really shouldn't do that. You
should not. That's fascinating.
So that's a real lesson for people.
So there's a lot of folks out here
that think is a lot of folks in him.
And to think like there's days when your
beat and exhausted and you got to push
through. You shouldn't push through,
you should not push through it.
You're doing damage to your body.
You're pushing yourself further and
further into exhaustion at something.
And now that doesn't mean that you
can't get up and do joint mobility,
stretching, Yin Yoga,
walking with the breath work.
Uh, you can go in and if you can hold
yourself back on of these kids are pretty
addicted to training, but you could also
do skill rehearsal. You could do drill,
you know,
if you're a do something that doesn't
push you and say you're a competitive Jiu
Jitsu guy, so you practice your favorite
sweep or you're bearing bolo or your,
your turtle guard, whatever. You do
that and you don't do anything hard.
Does your son Zack follow
all your principals? So all,
he's been a really good model of like
this type of intelligent training.
And he does not do supplementary training
other than strength training and lifts
weights and just,
yeah.
And he does this all monitoring
the heart rate and all that jazz.
That's fascinating. He's done really
well from savvy one brown belt worlds.
And uh, he's one of the few
guys actually built Kron Gracie.
He'd be crying to the Las Vegas black
bout. Uh, a challenge. No, look,
I was very impressed with Zach. Um, you
know, I knew who he was because of you,
you know,
you told me about him,
but then Eddie Bravo actually
told me about him and I said,
did you know that that's Steve Maxwell
son? He was like, holy, Whoa, no wonder,
you know, he was like, no
wonder it gives him a kid.
Must be a fucking animal growing up. Steve
Maxwell, he's an animal. He's an animal.
So if a guy wakes up, like say if your
normal resting heart rate is, you know,
for any leaf athletes,
let's say it's 40 beats a minute and
you wake up in one day, it's 45. Yeah.
You probably,
you definitely should take off that day
or stretch or just something like they
call it active recovery. Yes. Where it's
just one of moderate low level activity,
but definitely don't go beat
your brains out in the gym. Wow.
And so the people that do do that, that
thank you. Just gotta push through.
They're just being strong,
but being dumb.
They're being dumb because
there's going to work against e,
let's put it this way.
It's not what you can do in the gym.
It's what can you recover from it to gym.
Wow.
Cause all the magic happens from
rest. And Man, let's, let's,
I work out only has negative consequences.
You're blood pressure's elevated,
your must, Julie Weaker.
You've, you know, you've,
you've actually torn and broken
down muscle fiber, you know,
your whole hormonal system is lower.
It's that rest phase in between the
workouts where your body adapts and you
become stronger.
The more fit you become,
the longer it takes to recover because
you're able to push yourself harder and
harder.
A weak person that's not very fit.
They can't push themselves
hard enough to really, they,
they actually could probably work out
every day but a really fit strong guy like
yourself.
For example,
you can not drive yourself every day
cause each workout you're making sets a
demand on your body.
One thing that you cannot control
is your ability to recover.
It's set at the biologic
level. It's cellular man.
Unless you're doing steroids,
unless you join sterile, that changes
a lot. But even those guys still, uh,
they re one of the things that steroids
does do is it allows you to recover much,
much more quickly.
I wanted to talk to you about weight
cutting too because there was a really
fascinating thing today. There was
an article in bloody elbow about uh,
Jim Miller and Jim Miller
was talking about how he believes at
weight cutting took years off of his life.
And you know, I mean Jim looks fantastic
this weekend. He beat a Yancey Madeiros.
He is submitted them to get
tea and put them out. Actually,
first time I ever seen the guys celebrate
while I guys unconscious lying on him
like Jim is like this. And the guys
aren't completely out cold eyes open,
lying on top. And Yancey is a
fucking stud too. So it was,
it was a big victory for him.
Miller's a sick Jujitsu guy.
He submitted a Fabrizio coins in his
last fight who was one of 'em, uh,
one of boilers,
black belts.
So I caught him with a really slick
armbar this guy gotta be pretty dog gone
good.
Jim Miller is a bad motherfucker,
but he was talking about his
weight trop and uh, you know,
his weight cut that he's, you know, made
a lot of errors over the years and that,
uh, he, you know, he's fucked it up. But
you know, this is a direct quote. He says,
I'm positive.
I took years off my life cutting weight.
That's fucking crazy.
Well, have you think about it? Just
combat sports in itself. Like I said,
we had mentioned this several times
is no one ever said it's healthy.
It definitely shaved years off then
into your life. But, hey, look, man,
you can't just have,
I mean,
you could just be like some dude that
never did much and just sits around and
has a really nice long life. But
I mean, what the hell that man,
it's like, man, can't
just sit around. Right?
So like you take the typical
NFL football player, you know,
the average life expectancy
for an NFL football player,
I believe it was 64 years old. It's not
very old. It's Pr, you know, that's,
that's young dude. There's only three
more year years older than I am.
But if you were to ask those guys, hey,
was it all worth it? They'd say, hell or,
yeah, man, the roar of the crowd,
the adulation. You know, uh,
you know, the excitement of playing
at such a high, elite level of sport,
almost every guy too, man
would say, yeah, you know what,
I would take the shorter life for
the glory. But that aside, you know,
people that are just doing this for
fun as a hobby, they gotta be careful,
man.
They can't be doing all this crazy stuff.
You know these kids that go to the
local tournament's and this and that.
They're playing around with us
all this series weight cutting,
they're doing their, their health,
irreparable harm. Fight your damn,
wait and stop trying to get an unfair
advantage by cutting down and then gaining
back.
We'll look at some of the greats.
Look at Frankie Edgar constantly fought
guys much larger than I'm one the title
beat Bj Penn,
who also did the same thing.
Bj Penn fought below his
weight for his entire career,
fought fucking heavy weight
when he fought Leo Machida,
but Cheetah was like two oh eight when
they fought. It was pretty amazing.
Fucking crazy and held his
own. How does that, you know,
beat Matt Hughes who was a
monster at one 70 you know,
Bj Penn was the perfect example of a
guy who just fought anybody at any way.
The guy had no fear of man.
It's an animal and now he's fighting
at one 45 I know. It's incredible.
I mean, it's probably where he
should have been his entire career.
If you compare the athletes
today and what they're doing, but
even at one 45 he just
decided to alter his diet,
put it really intensified as training
and now he got down to like he's walking
around a little over 150 pounds so
he's not going to cut a lot of weight.
You know these guys that are
cutting like 25 30 pounds away.
I've seen guys shuffle up to the
scale like like death warmed over.
Travis Luter was the worst cadavers man,
Travis Luter when you fought Anderson
Silva miss the weight cut and a missed it,
tried it again,
missed it again,
and then wound up fighting for a non
title fight because he couldn't make the
weight and he was off by not much.
At the end it was only like a pound and
a half, but shuffling to the weight,
to the,
to the scale because he couldn't walk
and then they tried to rehydrate with
these ivs. Yeah, they take the ivy man.
There's no way that your body could
sustain that type of abuse and you'd be at
your best.
You're not going to be at your best.
The idea is though that you're going
to be theirs. Luder um, when he,
when he weighed in, it's hard to tell
from the photos how bad he looked.
He had to see him moving and walking.
Look how sunk in his eyes were though.
And he, um, I mean it's,
it's hard to tell from that picture how
much different he looks than he does
when he's normal and healthy
and full and ready to rock.
That was a guy that fucking massive
potential. He was such a good Jujitsu guy,
but until end of his career and
personal experience like a 1974,
I was gearing up for the uh, uh, uh,
and say, uh, double a tournament.
You know, we're getting into
the big tournament season.
I had a record of 18 children.
One at that time was really good
college wrestler I high level and uh,
somehow I got talked into going down
at one 58. I was doing great at one 67.
That was like my natural way. I
felt really good. I was strong.
Joe is a huge mistake. I ended up getting
the flu. I get sick. I felt like shit.
So you're probably already
lean at that way already.
Lane and you were cutting what?
How much did you drop out from one
67 to one 58 that's almost 10 pounds.
But what were you weighing when you
weighed one 67 what we walking around,
I usually about one 70 maybe we
only cut a little bit cause I,
I was a very strict even in those days,
even in my college days back in the
70s it was very strict about my diet.
There's a lot of people that are trying
to figure out the point of diminishing
returns. Like what is it when
it comes to weight cutting,
because you'll see guys that rehydrate
and they are beasts like glace and t bow.
That guy cuts almost 30 fucking pounds.
Well one of the things I really liked
about the moon jobs and the Pan ams,
you weigh in at the edge of the mat and
then you go out and you fight right then
and there. There's no cheating.
The scales can't do that.
For the UFC though I often wished they
would though because I'll tell you,
you would see, see the, the,
the abuse of weight loss,
but completely had to fight their own way.
I think that they should
fight their own weight.
And I think that's more in line with the
spirit of martial arts because why are
people losing weight while
they're trying to have
a mechanical advantage? Tall rangy
guys have that leverage strength, uh,
leverage advantage. I mean, you know,
strength advantage and then you know,
you'll lose this weight unnaturally
artificially and then, you know,
by fight time you're much,
much heavier.
It's kind of a form of cheating actually,
in my opinion.
In a way it is in a way it is,
but if everybody's doing it,
it almost is a necessity to compete at
the highest levels. That's the problem.
Well that is the problem. It's
just like the guys, you know,
like Lance Armstrong's look,
every body was taking the drugs.
How can you compete at that level in
the Tour de France if you don't? Well,
okay, but my point is no
one should be Jordan. Okay,
well the Lance Armstrong thing, the
problem was that he's a douchebag. Wow.
That's the problem. Sued everybody
for saying that he was taking drugs,
said everybody you know, look people in
the eye and said, you know, I never doped.
I never denied tasing my iron man. Not
Amazing. I didn't believe him. Nah,
not for a fucking second. Not For one
second. I had a friend, uh, my friend, uh,
is a, uh, former professional cyclist
and he told me, he just, he goes,
listen to me man. No one, no one's
clean. I go, no one. He goes,
no one's going. I could believe
that. He said, guys would get up.
He was on the tour and guys would
get up and they were, you know,
there were on a bus together,
guys would get up.
They would be on so much EPO that they
would have to take their bike out in the
middle of the night and run, cause their
blood would start getting sick. Oh Jesus.
Yeah. Oh Jesus. That's crazy stuff man.
He said you would hear the guy get their
bike rack off and you would hear them
just ride off and you knew exactly what
it was. Just trying to thin out of that.
You know,
I think we see it in fighters.
There's some fires at workout the day
before the fight. And why are they,
why we know why they do it. They have
to, they probably have to, you know,
why would you want to stress your
body out the day before a fight?
I mean it's one thing to get a light
workout and I don't switch it up.
Jumping rubbed some stretching,
a little yoga.
This guys who would work out
hard the day before and it also,
EPO wasn't even being tested in
Nevada until, I mean, I don't know.
I think they're testing for it now,
but for the longest time they weren't
testing for EPO because they thought it
was an endurance sport.
A problem,
like a thing like cycling and triathlons
and they didn't think that applied to
boxing, which I thought was like
one of the best pieces of evidence.
You've got fucking morons who are
dictating what gets tested and not tested.
Like you want to talk.
Just a complete ignorance of
what is involved in the sport.
Boxing is such an intensive adorne sport.
Amazing. And Jordan sport man, anywhere
in the dad. It just get in there,
do three minutes sometime in a boxing
gym and see the bag. It's absolutely,
utterly devastating if
you're not used to it.
Yeah. Jimmy, without anybody
ripping your body with left heart,
let alone taking the punches [inaudible]
addition and trying to breathe while
someone's punching you breathing.
Well that's the thing that Nick Diaz
always does to guys. People who say, well,
why does he punch like that?
Because like he'll throw it like a lot
of punches that aren't even that because
you can't breathe when he's hitting you
while he's hitting you, you're going,
you're tightening up.
So a few minutes that like
you've essentially held
your breath while he's just
rob had pop pop of, of
oxygen. Yeah. But uh,
one thing I was really
happy about the Moon Zhao,
they've finally started testing the
metal winners for the drugs for years.
They did not.
And when did they do this?
Is this has just been
the last couple of years.
That's very important because for
the longest time guys would come out,
look in purple,
they were bright. 70 guys are bragging
about the drugs that they were taking.
And finally they made it illegal.
They are now testing the,
the place winners in the Mungia
and you're suspended. Now,
I believe Zach told me this the other
night that, uh, I believe it's a year.
I don't know whether that's true or not.
I heard it's a year of suspension.
So no Jujitsu tournaments
would offer a year.
I think you should be
more like three years. But
well, that would really
make it real. You know,
the UFC does nine months for
the first offense, you know,
but they're really trying to crack down on
it. And now, you know, we have this, uh,
the TRT issue,
which I had Dr. Mark Gordon,
who is an expert in traumatic brain
injury who was talking to me about the,
you know, he's like, there's two reasons
why someone needs testosterone. Well,
this three, one year an older person
and your body starts to wane to,
you've suffered brain injuries,
three,
you took steroids and then you depleted
your system and now you have to
replenish it artificially. And so
finally they remove that from fighting,
which I think is very
important to have those things.
So traumatic brain injury for sure.
And then the steroid taking for sure.
And then if you're old,
you're, you're, you know,
you're a guy and he's in his forties
and you, you want to keep competing in.
The only way to do it with
is with testosterone. Boy,
you probably shouldn't be
fighting anymore, probably. No.
I mean it's a certain point
and it's a young man's game
and you can do things naturally,
uh,
to stimulate it as you get like my age.
Yeah. We're running out of time here.
Sorry. But, uh, yeah, just doing high
intensity interval training. Watts. Yeah.
Uh, ha. Uh, full body movement
patterns. Uh, big, big movements. Uh,
I like to run some sprints, wind sprints,
those type of things. You know, Short,
intense, uh, can really
stimulate the body to,
what do you think? If you studied
at all any of these new, uh,
this new gains that they're making in
genetic engineering and what they're
pushing for,
have you contemplated what this,
what the possibilities are for sports?
Because it's one of the things that
I'm more, I want to say concerned,
but fascinated at the
same time, you know, as a,
as a person who's standing outside of it,
I mean obviously I'm a commentator,
but science is so close to altering the,
the very genetics of a human being.
I mean, within our lifetime, 40,
50 years from now, Max, you're going
to see super athletes from the bottle,
you know, from the, from a test tube,
from a needle, from whatever it is,
genetic engineering,
keep
threatening. Anyway, it's going to happen.
I'm sure maybe at some point it's
still seems to be pretty off and
still a lot of theory and conjecture.
So, but what happens then? I mean,
how much do we lose if
we think about what,
what an athlete is when you admire
a guy like say a rocky Marciano,
a great boxer, or, or, uh, you know,
any great athlete from a time
where they weren't doing anything,
what do you admire them for?
You admire them for their willpower,
their determination, their, their focus,
their tenacity, the fact that this guy,
they're there, their workmanship, the
work ethic. Work Ethic. When I was a kid,
when I lived in Boston,
Mohammed Ali was gonna
Fight Mustapha Hampshire and
Muhammad Ali was one of them.
Will Spartan training, excuse me, not
Muhammad Ali. Jesus Christ. Marvin Hagler.
Well, I was going to fight.
We'll stop at Hampshire.
I can't put this in Muhammad Ali because
I was thinking about him as another
example of a great athlete who just
trained hard and an Arrow with no drugs.
But Marvin Hagler was going to fight
Mustapha Ham show and he was training for
it and Cape Cod in the winter.
And one of the reasons why I did those,
cause he would run the sand dunes and
just because he loved the fact that he's
in the fucking brutal cold of the
Cape cod running by the ocean.
And I remember they had a thing on the
news where they were hyping up the fight
and they're going through his training
regime and he was running up sand dunes,
screaming war, screaming, just whoa.
And just running and shadow boxing. And
I saw that and I went running, I ran,
I ran stairs near my house.
There was,
this is stairs near this bridge near my
house. And I went running. I was like,
fuck. But you know, he's instead,
he's sitting there and they're pumping
them full of EPO and they're monitoring
his blood and you know,
giving them artificial this and
genetic that and what, what,
what is a Bot?
I mean,
remember Drago in Russia and the fucking
in the rocky for when he saw Stallone
was fucking running with logs in his
back to the snow and they have Drago,
they're spiking them with steroids. And
I left in a cart full of rocks, you know?
Well, you know we've already done
to our food with genetic modified.
It's inevitable though. Like
I, but they're going to do
it to the human body also.
I meant who knows? But what does
that have to say about athletics?
What does athletics going to
be when that happens? Well,
it sure isn't going to be what we knew
it to be and it's sure not as sure strays
far from the,
the idea that carrot is for 2000 years,
which was the ancient Greek ideal.
Our generation degrees or generations
would probably the last generations to
know what privacy feels like. Like
real true privacy. You know when,
when when you were a kid
you could leave the house,
you could just fuck off and go anywhere
and nobody had any idea where you are.
Your parents hoped he came home and that's
about it. That's pretty much it, man.
My mom sent me out with a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich and a brown bag,
say see it dinner and that was it.
I remember we got an answering machine,
make it,
somebody could leave a message when you
weren't home making tree forts and all
sorts of crazy stuff. The, the era
of genetic manipulation though,
surely like right around the corner,
we're within our lifetime within 40,
50 years.
So
I don't know,
but uh,
probably when it goes into full swing and
becomes completely accepted by society,
I guess I'll probably be dead
by that point. So I dunno dude,
I have a feeling you're
gonna live a long time.
I have a feeling you're going
to be around for a long time.
You kind of plan it for it to,
your diet is very unusual in that respect.
Has Gotten very spartan and the systematic
underrating has shown to be one of
the keys to longevity
systematic under eating.
How many cows do you mark your calories?
Uh, I, I use an Okinawan, you know,
Okinawa or like one of the, uh, that,
that blue zone where people like an
unusual amount of lift to be centenarians.
Very high level.
There's another blue zone is Ikaria
Greece where there's an unusual amount of
people that live to be over a hundred
years old. Part of it's genetics,
but a lot of it is the lifestyle.
It's the lack of stress and so forth.
But any rate the Okinawans
have to sing. Uh, 80%.
You never leave the table
feeling satisfied. You
never eat until you're full.
You leave 80% capacity. So I, okay.
Why did they do that? What's,
what's the philosophy behind that?
The idea is if you overburden
judge digestion by over
eating or making yourself
feel full, it's too much of
an innovation on the system.
It takes more out of you than
what you get out of your food.
So that has been something that they,
it's ingrained in their culture for a long
time. It's ingrained in their culture.
Wow. So this is something they
figured out a long time ago.
They figured this out a long time ago.
It goes way back to ancient times.
They also get a lot of coral
calcium too, right? Isn't that like
part of the, do they, you know,
they have a lot of mineralization from
their fish broth and so forth and they
eat a very, very, a simple
pretty spartan diet. Really.
I mean,
it's very simple.
Now in these days, how much time
we're going to lift Jimmy? Five,
five minutes these days. Um, do you
roll it all anymore? Do you still,
I was just down in Arcadia, uh, uh,
roller round at Carson Gracie school.
Now do you make sure that
you don't go with any crises?
Don't go on. Let me, well,
you know,
I'm a busy dude,
fifth degree Blackbaud now and a lot
of times I am a little bit younger than
what I look,
so kids don't see a 61 year old dude.
They see like, oh, I'm good right now.
So I gotta be very careful who I choose.
I would like to do a light roles.
Usually the instructor of the
school's pretty good. Yeah.
You know, and he'd go in with a lot
of the melody, you know, for sure.
Get permission before you go to these
schools. You just don't show up.
And put the guy in the
spot. Right, right, right.
They might think you're challenging or
something and they want to show off in
front of the students or whatever.
So I'm very, very careful.
I like to roll with a guide.
Your guys.
I try not to roll with a
really heavy guys anymore.
Yeah, I'm done with heavy guys. It's
just so bad for your back. Yeah, no,
it is it back. It just any guy
over 200 pounds stacking you.
It's just too much on your, your joints
and your especially your spine. Like,
like here on Gracie. Apparently
I want to talk to him about this,
but he's got a numb arm.
Yes.
I,
I do an awful lot of joint mobility work.
I actually teach a specific anti aging
mobility routine DVD on it. Yeah.
Uh, a video downloads. Actually I,
I've switched from DVDs to downloads.
I have the DVD. I'm old school.
Yeah. There you bought it
years ago. But, uh, yeah,
mobility is really important, but I've
changed my boat belty over the years.
Now I've learned new things and have
incorporated new ideas so I should get the
new one. Yeah, I think so. I'll send
it to you. Where do I get it from?
If somebody was listening to this,
it's Steve, Matt, it's Maxwell,
sc.com maximal strength and conditioning
SC Maxwell as well as c.com.com.
The website. That's everything.
And um, I'll send you the link.
You just write me and I'll send
you the links. And your, um,
your Twitter though is Steve Maxwell,
sc two. Steve Maxwell. I see. Um,
so if someone wants to get a strength
and conditioning program from you,
you do all that stuff online, right? I
do. And you have a lot of videos online.
There's a lot of cool stuff that
videos and stuff. I'm walking,
I'm always trying to, you know, uh,
improve myself. I'm still a student.
I don't care how long you've
been in the game, man.
He could still learn new things.
And so it's an ever evolving thing.
And of course as they get older,
I have to change up too. I mean,
no one gets out of here alive.
Everyone, you know, your,
your capacity does diminish
over time and you feel the bump,
but you can really slow it down to a
crawl. As long as you continue to push,
you got to do some push.
You got to constantly give fight
against the aging process. Um,
you were also a god, we're running out
of time here. I wish we weren't. Um,
you were in Russia recently.
I was doing some Novosibirsk went
there on your own dime just too darn.
I was working with a conditional cough
who was the father of a Russian military
martial arts. It was pretty interesting.
This guy is like 80 years old,
kind of like you Nelia Gracie kind of guy,
man.
He put me in the most painful wrist
lock. This guy was, he was saying,
do something to me in Russian and uh,
getting the translation, I'm thinking,
Oh shit, what do I gotta
do this Old Nan? And Wow,
that guy is really a main, very
soft, relaxed, uh, martial art.
He was the creator of this particular
Russian military martial art. And it's a,
it's all geared towards military
and self defense. What does it have?
Its roots in a Slavic martial arts.
That was earlier.
There was a guy by the nearer spirit,
enough that a study Chinese and, and uh,
different internal systems. And then, uh,
he taught it to Kadesh nick coffee and
then conditional cough and mixed it with
some slot native Slavic type
martial arts. And it, it's uh,
he also created the biomechanical
exercises for the body mobility drills for
health and wellbeing. Uh, good for
any sportsman wrestlers, Jujitsu guys.
So I'm teaching a lot of this stuff now.
I've incorporated into my own,
my own system. Fascinating. So when
you go and meet with the garlic,
that and learn and stuff, are you
videotaping, answering? No, not enough.
Your types of loud. So how did you, uh,
you just remembered what he said
and then I have a real good memory.
Took notes on my iPhone and so forth.
The one I have lost. Thank God.
Thank God for iclicker. Ah, they'd
go, you backed it up. Um, so you, you,
it's systemic. Is that what it is? Yeah,
it's called systemic and there's
a couple of branches to systemic.
This is the original system.
There's the group up in Toronto that
does their version, the Michael Ratko,
that's like the phantom punches.
And that's what I've seen a lot.
A lot of that is rad goes punched his
guys and he hurts when he punches.
It really hurts.
And what he does is he'll,
he'll show the fist and the guys just
fall down because they don't want to get
hurt. So he really is controlling them
psychically, just by intimidating him.
So he's just a hard puncher that's got
a bunch of pussy whipped students pretty
much. But their students are pretty
tough guys. But there's something to it.
It's the breath work.
You know,
Hixon came out of retirement and a is
doing the seminar circuit blackbelt friend
of mine in Germany, Bjorn Friedrich, he
was the first German blackbelt and Bjj.
He took Hixon seminar and he says, wow,
he spent the first hour just a breath,
work and relaxation.
And that's what the systemic guys,
Joe will crone was talking about
that on the podcast as well.
It's funny cause the Gracies all
did it but they never taught us.
But now the revealing the secret and
it really does go back to the breath.
I would love to be, this could be a
whole podcast in itself. Just breath,
just the breathwork.
Well when he back in la again,
well it may be sooner than later.
I'm thinking about doing another video
downloaded at some of the stuff I learned
in Russia and I'm going to do three foot
long workouts that guys can do in their
hotel room or while they're on the
road, uh, anytime, anyplace, anywhere.
And I'm going to actually do a full on
workout and I love this videographer out
here. I shot a, a a trailer
for a possible reality TV show.
And uh, that's what I was doing
here in La, the plus a book deal.
I had an article in the march issue of
men's health and it attracted a lot of
attention.
So I had an offer to come out and shoot
a trailer maybe to pitch some people
cause I am a pretty weird dude man. Yeah,
you're pretty weird dude. A bag, you know,
I don't have a key.
I don't have no kids cause I don't
have any locks to need him for.
I don't know why.
Apartment or a house.
And that doesn't ever freak
you out sometimes, you know,
being a former householder and yeah.
You know,
having a gym and a house and cars
and everything could go back to that.
Is this temporary hailed a, once
you leave all that stuff, it's,
it's suffering man. Wow. It's like
real freedom. You're an inspiration.
Steve Maxwell. You're a bad motherfucker.
Hey, you are too, Joe. Thanks.
Appreciate you coming on. And
that has a lot of fun. So folks,
Maxwell [inaudible] dot com, um, uh,
Theresa gave me some stuff to,
uh,
to read about a year in the
u s till the 24th of May. Uh,
you have a seminar in Buffalo,
a 4th of May.
Unfortunately it's sold out New York
3rd of May, Toronto, 10th of May.
Uh, PDX, which I guess is Polk.
Portland. That's what they're called.
PDX Portland, Oregon. What does
PDX, why they call it? Okay.
That's the 17th and 18th of May in
Indianapolis, the 24th of May. Again,
all of this available on
Maxwell, sc.com. Steve Maxwell,
sc on Twitter.
Anything else? Yeah, rev gear.
There's a NMA expo in San Antonio,
Texas. August one, two three.
I'm teaching kettlebells
specifically for martial arts,
MMA, Jujitsu. So get get if you,
if you want to learn about cannibis or
how's it teach them better get to the rev
rev gear, uh, uh, expo.
It's an MMA expo and will all this
be on your website as well? Yeah,
this is going to be on the website
and check out rev gear man.
Maxwell S c.com. Steve
Maxwell laser. Gentlemen,
thank you very much sir and thanks to
our sponsors. Thanks to Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com and
use the code word Joe.
Save yourself some cash. Thanks also
to onnit.com that's o. N N. I t.
Use the codeword Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
We'll be back tomorrow with
Dave Attell on Thursday.
We got Greg Fitzsimmons, and then
we're also doing the a UFC. Um,
I want to say wrap up analysis,
post fight with Brendan Schaub and Brian
Cowen, uh, the fighter and the kid.
So that's a two podcasts on Thursday.
And then Friday night,
I'll see you guys at the Lobero theater
in Santa Barbara with Joey Diaz.
It's almost sold out.
It might be sold out this week.
I'm not sure if it was pretty close the
other day. All right. Much love everybody.
Big Kiss.
Ooh.